I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, Angela. Hi, Jenna. You're fighting with a staple right now. I was hoping to have it done before the music stopped. No, you're still working on it. Guys, I did this thing where I printed my document. You know, Jenna and I both do documents now, guys. I've moved on from note cards to online. I know. I don't know how I feel about it. I still have some
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。你好，安吉拉。嗨，珍娜。你现在正在和订书机较劲。我本希望在音乐停止前把它弄好的。不，你还在弄它。伙计们，我刚才打印了我的文档。你们知道，珍娜和我都开始用文档了，伙计们。我已经从笔记卡片转为在线文档了。我知道。我不知道自己对此感觉如何。我还有一些
post-it notes, okay? Okay. You know, post-it notes still happen. And I color code everything. As you know, my document is all kinds of different colors. But this morning when I was printing it, I by accident printed the font to like size 40. It's so many pages. It's so many pages. It's like a phone book. And the staple would not staple at all. It wouldn't. It was poking me. Hi, guys. Welcome to Office, ladies. Today we're talking about Secret Santa. But today in real life, it's St. Patrick's Day. It is. So we're kind of doing a holiday on a holiday. Mm-hmm. I'd like to say something before we get started. We have been together in the studio for 15 minutes so far this morning, and no one has mentioned my cute, sassy new
便利贴，好吗？好的。你知道，便利贴还是很有用的。而且我用颜色对所有东西进行了分类。如你所知，我的文档里有各种不同的颜色。但今天早上打印的时候，我不小心把字体调到了40号左右。页数太多了。页数太多了。简直像本电话簿。而且订书机根本订不上。真的订不上。它一直在戳我。嗨，大家好。欢迎来到《办公室》女士。今天我们要聊的是“秘密圣诞老人”。但在现实生活中，今天是圣帕特里克节。确实是。所以我们是在节日里过另一个节日。嗯。在开始之前我想说点什么。我们今天早上在演播室待了15分钟了，还没人提到我可爱、俏皮的新
haircut. I noticed it right away when I was complaining about my printer issues. I know, but no one has complimented my hair. It looks very nice. I apologize. And I need the compliments. I'm fishing for the compliments. I thought you looked like a runway model when I saw you this morning. I said, who is that lady? She looks like a million bucks. Oh my God. It's my boss lady fringe and a fisher. Thank you. And you know what's setting it all off? What? Sassy haircut. Good. It starts with the sassy haircut, and then it goes all the way down. You have a whole outfit. She has a little green stripy shirt, a cardigan, cute, cute accessories. I cannot tell if this is genuine or if this is sarcasm. Sam, where do you stand
发型。我刚才抱怨打印机问题时就注意到了。我知道，但没人夸我的头发。它看起来很不错。我道歉。我需要赞美。我是在寻求赞美。我今天早上看到你时，觉得你看起来像个走秀模特。我说，那位女士是谁？她看起来气场十足。天哪。这是我的老板娘刘海和费舍尔。谢谢。你知道是什么让它更出彩吗？什么？俏皮的发型。很好。从俏皮的发型开始，然后一直延伸到全身。你有一整套行头。她穿着一件绿色条纹小衬衫，一件开衫，还有可爱、可爱的配饰。我无法分辨这是真心的还是讽刺。萨姆，你对此怎么看？
on this? This is genuine. I think it's how I labeled it before. I think it's genuine and hostile. It can be both. Angela's in a mood today. They said I came in hot this morning, y'all. I came in hot. Angela walked in, looked at the video camera, so Cassie can see it and said, no, and tore it out of the wall instead of just asking to move it. They have this camera, guys, so we can be on Zoom with Cassie. And it literally, I don't know what evil person set it up today, but it was a shot under my neck and up my nose. It was not, it was not good. It wasn't. I'm going to back you up on that. You know what, a woman who's just recently turned 50 doesn't need an under the neck shot. You know what
这是真心的。我想这就是我之前给它贴的标签。我觉得它既真心又充满敌意。两者皆可。安吉拉今天心情不好。他们说我今天早上来的时候火气很大，伙计们。我火气很大。安吉拉走进来，看着摄像机，为了让卡西能看到，然后说“不”，直接把它从墙上扯了下来，而不是要求移动它。伙计们，他们有这个摄像头，这样我们就能和卡西进行Zoom通话了。真的，我不知道是哪个邪恶的人今天把它装成这样，但它拍的角度是从我脖子下面往上拍到鼻孔。这真的很糟糕，真的很糟糕。我支持你的说法。你知道吗，一个刚满50岁的女人不需要那种从脖子下面往上拍的镜头。你知道它
it looked like? You know, when you go on Instagram and you haven't angled the camera right yet, but it's on selfie mode, it's that horrifying moment where you see yourself from like under the neck. Yes. That's how the Zoom camera was. So yeah, Sam, I ripped it out of the wall. Angela, can I ask you a St. Patty's Day question? Oh, please. Will you be getting tooted today? That got my husband so tickled because my husband, Josh, listens to the podcast and I saw him when we all posted. He was like, are we getting tooted, babe? All right. Well, let's get into it. Okay. This is season six, episode 13, written by Mindy Kaling, directed by Randall Einhorn. This episode features a song from Green Day.
看起来像什么吗？你知道，当你上Instagram，还没调整好摄像头角度，但它处于自拍模式时，那种从脖子下面看自己的恐怖时刻吗？是的。Zoom摄像头就是那样。所以，是的，萨姆，我把它从墙上扯下来了。安吉拉，我能问你一个关于圣帕特里克节的问题吗？哦，请问。你今天会“鸣笛”吗？这让我丈夫觉得很有趣，因为我丈夫乔什会听这个播客，我们发帖时我看到了他。他说，宝贝，我们要“鸣笛”吗？好吧，让我们开始吧。好的。这是第六季第13集，由敏迪·卡灵编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩执导。这一集里有一首绿日乐队的歌。
And y'all know I'm friends with Billy Joe Armstrong, lead singer of Green Day. Jenna is blushing as she's saying this. She's blushing. I am such a fan of my own friend. It's true. I reached out and he agreed to read the summary. So here it is. Oh my gosh. Hello, office ladies listeners. This is Billy Joe Armstrong. Here's your summary for Secret Santa. It's Christmas time and Dunder Mifflin. Jim and Dwight are in charge of this year's Christmas party and they are doing a pretty good job. Jim tells Phyllis she can play Santa, something she's wanted to do for years. This naturally causes Michael to spiral. Meanwhile, Oscar has a crush on a new warehouse worker and Pam plays matchmaker. Andy has Aaron in the Secret Santa gift exchange,
你们都知道我和绿日乐队的主唱比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗是朋友。珍娜说这话时脸红了。她在脸红。我真是自己朋友的粉丝。这是真的。我联系了他，他同意读一下剧情简介。所以，就是这样。天哪。你好，《办公室》女士的听众们。我是比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗。这是你们的“秘密圣诞老人”剧情简介。圣诞节到了邓德·米夫林公司。吉姆和德怀特负责今年的圣诞派对，他们做得相当不错。吉姆告诉菲利斯她可以扮演圣诞老人，这是她多年来一直想做的事。这自然导致迈克尔陷入了混乱。与此同时，奥斯卡暗恋着一位新的仓库员工，帕姆则充当了红娘。安迪在秘密圣诞老人礼物交换中抽到了艾琳，
but so far it's not going well. She's mostly just been attacked by birds. There's some potentially devastating news from corporate hanging over everyone's heads. But in the end, it's a great party with karaoke, a marching band, and even a little snow. I'll walk a lonely road. We all walk a lonely road. I mean, come on. Come on. He's the best. Come on. When he sang at the end, I was like, why? We're all grinning. Oh, thank you. Thank you so much, Billy Joe. Thank you, Billy Joe. All right. Fast fact number one, this episode aired on December 10th, 2009. But shortly afterward, there was an extended cut that was released and it included nine extra minutes of footage, which brought the total length of the episode
但到目前为止进展并不顺利。她基本上只是被鸟攻击了。公司传来了一些可能具有毁灭性的消息，笼罩在每个人的心头。但最终，这是一个很棒的派对，有卡拉OK、行进乐队，甚至还有一点雪。“我走在孤独的路上。”我们都走在孤独的路上。我是说，拜托。拜托。他是最棒的。拜托。当他在最后唱歌时，我心想，为什么？我们都在咧嘴笑。哦，谢谢。非常感谢你，比利·乔。谢谢你，比利·乔。好的，第一个速记事实，这一集于2009年12月10日播出。但不久之后，发布了一个加长剪辑版，包含了九分钟的额外镜头，使这一集的总时长达到了
up to 29 minutes and 43 seconds. Oh, I have so much to share about this. I know you do. Okay. So there are no deleted scenes. If you have the DVD box set, there are no deleted scenes for Secret Santa. And it is because of this extended producers cut. I guess there were so many great scenes they decided to make like our version back then of a super size, right? Yeah. So I reached out to Joya Balfour. You guys, I've spoken about her before. She worked for NBC Digital. And I was like, Joya, what did you know about this extended producers cut? And she said, Angela, it was made for NBC.com. Oh, yes. And it was actually the first producers cut episode that they ran exclusively on NBC.com. Wow. That's right.
29分43秒。哦，关于这个我有太多要分享的了。我知道你有。好的。所以没有删除的场景。如果你有DVD套装，秘密圣诞老人那一集没有删除场景。这是因为这个制片人加长剪辑版。我想是因为有太多精彩的场景，他们决定制作一个我们当时版本的“超大版”，对吧？是的。所以我联系了乔亚·巴尔福。伙计们，我之前提到过她。她曾在NBC数字部门工作。我问她，乔亚，关于这个制片人加长剪辑版你知道些什么？她说，安吉拉，它是为NBC.com制作的。哦，是的。而且它实际上是他们专门在NBC.com上播放的第一集制片人剪辑版。哇。没错。
A few more will come as we go through the seasons, but this is the full list of extended producers cuts that ran on NBC.com. Pretty quickly, right after the episode aired, you could go to NBC.com and there they were. Secret Santa, Training Day, Search Committee, Angry Andy and Fundraiser. Wow. And it was the first time we had ever done that. Of course now, all networks have websites and have episodes up there, but this was the first time it was ever done for NBC, for our show. I want to say, I feel like the folks at NBC.com were kind of trailblazers here. Yeah. Like they were creating really cool extra content, original content kind of before everyone else was doing it. At least that's my perception. That's
随着我们继续拍摄后续几季，还会出现更多，但这是在NBC.com上播放的制片人加长剪辑版的完整列表。在这一集播出后很快，你就可以去NBC.com，它们就在那里。秘密圣诞老人、培训日、搜寻委员会、愤怒的安迪和筹款活动。哇。这是我们第一次这样做。当然，现在所有的电视网都有网站，上面都有剧集，但这在NBC对我们的节目来说还是第一次。我想说，我觉得NBC.com的人当时算是先驱。是的。他们创造了非常酷的额外内容，原创内容，在其他人开始做之前。至少我是这么认为的。那是
what I think too. The webisodes, putting extended episodes online, having digital shorts like my Adventures with Angela. Yes. So I went digging in my digital clutter and I found an email that Joya and I had back and forth during this episode where she was coming to set to film me for the segment I would do for NBC.com called Adventures with Angela. And I was going to give a holiday behind the scenes tour of the set. Well, Joya couldn't find the video, but guess what she shared with me. She said, Angela, I have found someone at NBC that I knew back in the day when she worked there. They told me that all of my videos, my Adventures with Angela segments were moved to the archive room and they're
我也这么认为。网络剧集，把加长剧集放到网上，还有像《安吉拉的冒险》这样的数字短片。是的。所以我翻找了我的数字杂物，发现了一封乔亚和我在这集期间往来的邮件，当时她要来片场拍摄我为NBC.com制作的名为《安吉拉的冒险》的片段。我要做一个节日幕后片场导览。好吧，乔亚找不到那个视频了，但猜猜她和我分享了什么。她说，安吉拉，我找到了一个我在NBC工作时认识的人。他们告诉我，我所有的视频，我的《安吉拉的冒险》片段都被移到了档案室，它们在
on a special server, but her friend there is going to try to get me all of them. I know. I would be so excited to have them. I remember you doing this one for Secret Santa because I remember you giving a tour of all the decorations and it was really cute. I remember doing these segments. They were so much fun. And Joya said that there's some more fun digital content coming up. NBC.com was really starting to get in a groove. And she said for season seven, she's going to have a lot of little nuggets for us. Oh, that is very exciting. Quick shout out, you guys, to Dunderpedia because they list all of these extra scenes. Oh, yes, I saw that. And I'm going to mention a few of them, but there's so many. There's so many.
一个特殊的服务器上，但她在那里工作的朋友会试着帮我把它们全部找回来。我知道。如果能拥有它们，我会非常兴奋。我记得你为“秘密圣诞老人”做了这个，因为我记得你带大家参观了所有的装饰，真的很可爱。我记得做这些片段。它们太有趣了。乔亚说还有更多有趣的数字内容即将推出。NBC.com真的开始进入状态了。她说对于第七季，她会为我们准备很多小彩蛋。哦，那太令人兴奋了。伙计们，快速向邓德百科（Dunderpedia）致敬，因为他们列出了所有这些额外场景。哦，是的，我看到了。我会提到其中的几个，但实在太多了。太多了。
So if you go to Dunderpedia or if you have the DVD box set, you can watch this extended producer's cut. Fastback number two is a Secret Santa deep dive. Oh, I'm so excited. I was a lady who Googled four different articles from Bustle, Wikipedia, USA Today and Grunge. What did they say? Well, since, you know, the Secret Santa gift exchange is such a big part of this episode, I wanted to know more. And I found out that lots of places have a tradition of exchanging or giving gifts in this Secret Santa tradition, but they have different names. I love different names. Me too. I love to see how people celebrate things differently like around the world. Me too. Well, in the UK, it's called Chris
所以如果你去邓德百科或者你有DVD套装，你可以观看这个制片人加长剪辑版。第二个速记事实是关于“秘密圣诞老人”的深度挖掘。哦，我太兴奋了。我是一个谷歌搜索了来自Bustle、维基百科、今日美国和Grunge四篇不同文章的女士。他们说了什么？好吧，因为你知道，秘密圣诞老人礼物交换是这一集的重要组成部分，我想了解更多。我发现很多地方都有在秘密圣诞老人传统中交换或赠送礼物的习俗，但它们有不同的名字。我喜欢不同的名字。我也是。我喜欢看世界各地的人们如何以不同的方式庆祝事物。我也是。好吧，在英国，它被称为克里斯·克林格尔。
Kringle. In Ireland, it's called Chris Kindle, which is an adaptation of Christ Kindle, which means Christ child. It's not Secret Santa there. It'd be Secret Chris Kringle. Yeah, but I don't even think you say the secret part. I think you just say, let's do a Chris Kindle gift exchange. Oh, okay. In Germany, it's called Wichlin, which means goblin or else. Now, some people believe that the whole thing originated in Scandinavia, where it's called juklop and involves basically leaving a gift at someone's door, knocking and then running away. But in all of these traditions, there's one thing that remains constant, which is that you have to give somebody a gift in secret, either out of the goodness of your
在爱尔兰，它被称为克里斯·金德尔，这是对“基督圣婴”的改编，意思是基督之子。那里不叫秘密圣诞老人。那应该是秘密克里斯·克林格尔。是的，但我甚至不认为你会说“秘密”那个部分。我想你只是说，让我们进行一次克里斯·金德尔礼物交换。哦，好的。在德国，它被称为Wicheln，意思是小妖精或精灵。现在，有些人认为这一切起源于斯堪的纳维亚，在那里它被称为juklop，基本上包括把礼物留在某人的门口，敲门然后跑掉。但在所有这些传统中，有一件事是不变的，那就是你必须秘密地给某人送礼物，要么是出于好心，
heart or through an organized gift exchange where you like draw names as in our episode. But ultimately, you are not supposed to reveal your identity. So many of these articles pointed to a philanthropist from Lee Summit, Missouri named Larry Dean Stewart as, quote, the original Secret Santa, like in America. Oh, okay. Who the name Secret Santa might come from. So the tradition of giving out secret gifts has been going on forever, but this name Secret Santa was sort of originally given to this man. Oh, I want to hear all about it. He gave out anonymous gifts during the holidays for more than 25 years. He would walk around wearing sometimes a red sweater. I saw one photo of him in like white overalls with a red sweater
要么是通过像我们这一集中那样抽签的组织性礼物交换。但归根结底，你不应该透露你的身份。许多文章都指出，一位来自密苏里州李峰市的慈善家，名叫拉里·迪恩·斯图尔特，是美国“最初的秘密圣诞老人”。哦，好的。秘密圣诞老人这个名字可能就是由此而来。所以秘密送礼的传统由来已久，但“秘密圣诞老人”这个名字最初是给这个人的。哦，我想听听关于他的一切。他在节日期间匿名送礼超过25年。他会四处走动，有时穿着一件红毛衣。我看到过一张他的照片，穿着白色工装裤，配着一件红毛衣
and a little red hat. And he would give people $100 bills just randomly. After 9 11, he donated over $25,000 in the form of $100 bills to New Yorkers. He was so famous for handing out this money that he was profiled in USA Today one year, but they kept it anonymous. They didn't say who he was. Aw. But his identity was finally revealed in 2006 after he was diagnosed with cancer. It was a pretty aggressive form of cancer. And what I read in an article was that someone knew who he was and they were going to reveal him. So he decided to come out and say who he was. But according to this article in USA Today, he was quoted as saying he has no strict criteria for who gets the money. He sometimes worked with local
和一顶红色小帽子。他会随机给人们100美元的钞票。9/11事件后，他以100美元钞票的形式向纽约人捐赠了超过25,000美元。他因分发这些钱而非常出名，以至于有一年《今日美国》对他进行了专题报道，但他们保持了匿名。他们没有说他是谁。啊。但他的身份最终在2006年他被诊断出患有癌症后被揭露。那是一种相当严重的癌症。我在一篇文章中读到，有人知道他是谁，并打算揭露他。所以他决定站出来说出自己的身份。但根据《今日美国》的这篇文章，他被引用说，他对于谁能得到钱没有严格的标准。他有时与当地的
service agencies or he had police officers or firefighters help him identify people who had been devastated by a fire or some other calamity. And he sometimes gave those people $1,000 or more. But he said most of the money he gave away was handed out to people that he met on the street in diners and laundromats, pawn shops and fast food places. In the article it also explained how he grew up really struggling and rather poor. And one day he was so hungry that he went to a diner and he ordered a big meal and he couldn't pay for it. And so he pretended like he lost his wallet. And the server came over to him and said, oh sir, I think you dropped this. And it was a $20 bill. Aw. Just protected his dignity in that
服务机构合作，或者让警察或消防员帮助他识别那些因火灾或其他灾难而遭受重创的人。他有时会给这些人1000美元或更多。但他表示，他分发的大部分钱都是给他在街上、餐馆、自助洗衣店、典当行和快餐店遇到的人。文章还解释了他小时候生活得非常艰难，相当贫穷。有一天他饿极了，走进一家餐馆点了一顿大餐，却付不起钱。于是他假装丢了钱包。服务员走过来对他说，哦，先生，我想你掉了这个。那是一张20美元的钞票。啊。就在那一刻保护了他的尊严。
moment. Right. Yeah. And he walked out of the diner. It didn't occur to him what this person had done for him until after he got outside. And then when he made a lot of money, he wanted to go around and give that back. And he actually went back and he found that guy who had given him the $20. The waiter? Yes. And then gave him a bunch of money. And the guy was like, no, you don't have to do that. And he said, well, you started it all. So it is estimated that in his lifetime, he gave away $1.3 million. Wow. And there's your original secret Santa. All right. So fast back number three, we found some kittens the week we were shooting this episode. This is like one of those things, guys. It's like
对。是的。他走出了餐馆。直到他走到外面，他才意识到那个人为他做了什么。后来当他赚了很多钱时，他想四处走动，把钱回馈给社会。他实际上回去找到了那个给他20美元的人。那个服务员？是的。然后给了他一大笔钱。那个人说，不，你没必要这么做。他说，好吧，是你开启了一切。据估计，他一生中捐出了130万美元。哇。这就是你们最初的秘密圣诞老人。好的，第三个速记事实，我们在拍摄这一集的那周发现了一些小猫。这就像是那种事情，伙计们。就像是
is art imitating life or life imitating art because here I had made up the story of finding sprinkles in the parking lot. And then years later, we found kittens in the parking lot. Yeah. This was the last episode before our big hiatus. Our costume designer, Alicia, and our property manager, Tom Melby found two kittens under the costume trailer. Little bitty kitten. They were so cute. And Alicia brought them in and I went in for wardrobe fitting and I saw them. Well, at this time, I was working with kitten rescue. And so I ended up taking these kittens home. Jenna fostered them, tell them their names. Dunder and Mifflin. Dunder was a little black and white tuxedo cat and Mifflin was an all black
艺术模仿生活还是生活模仿艺术，因为在这里我编造了在停车场发现Sprinkles的故事。然后几年后，我们在停车场发现了小猫。是的。这是我们大假期前的最后一集。我们的服装设计师艾丽西亚和我们的物业经理汤姆·梅尔比在服装拖车下发现了两只小猫。小小的猫。它们太可爱了。艾丽西亚把它们带了进来，我进去试装时看到了它们。好吧，当时我正在和猫咪救援组织合作。所以我最终把这些小猫带回了家。珍娜收养了它们，告诉大家它们的名字。邓德和米夫林。邓德是一只黑白相间的燕尾服猫，米夫林是一只全黑的
cat. But you know, Mifflin was struggling a little bit. I mean, these were barely weaned kittens and Dunder could eat on his own, but Mifflin couldn't. So I gave Mifflin to a volunteer at kitten rescue who had experienced bottle feeding babies. And eventually they were both adopted together, these little brothers by this young woman named Carrie. And I'm still in touch with her. She still sends me pictures of these guys. It's the sweetest thing. So I reached out to find out how they're doing. She said they are now 12 years old. Wow. She said that Dunder, who used to be kind of the more rascally outgoing one, has become a little crankier in his old age. He kind of hides when people come over now. Whereas
猫。但你知道，米夫林当时有点挣扎。我是说，这些几乎还没断奶的小猫，邓德可以自己吃东西，但米夫林不行。所以我把米夫林交给了一位有喂奶经验的猫咪救援志愿者。最终它们都被同一个年轻女子凯莉收养了，这两个小兄弟。我仍然和她保持联系。她仍然会给我发这些家伙的照片。这是最甜蜜的事情。所以我联系了她，想知道它们过得怎么样。她说它们现在12岁了。哇。她说邓德，以前是那种比较淘气外向的，在老年时变得有点暴躁了。现在有人来时它会躲起来。而
Mifflin, who was always kind of the shy one, loves to get pets from anybody who visits. So you know, Carrie also ended up being a foster parent for kittens at kitten rescue. And she told me that Dunder and Mifflin have helped to foster uncle, or as she calls it, old, over 80 kittens in the past 12 years. Wow. And that they're very, very good with all the little kittens that she fosters. It's funny because when I was working with kitten rescue, I think I gave an interview where I said that I had fostered and found homes for over 13 cats. And that got printed as I had 13 cats. And it took me years to get that corrected. It was on Wikipedia forever. And every time I would do an interview, someone
米夫林，一直以来比较害羞的那只，喜欢从任何来访者那里得到抚摸。所以你知道，凯莉最终也成为了猫咪救援组织的寄养家长。她告诉我，邓德和米夫林在过去12年里帮助寄养了，或者用她的话说，照顾了超过80只小猫。哇。而且它们对她寄养的所有小猫都非常好。很有趣，因为当我在猫咪救援组织工作时，我想我接受过一次采访，我说我寄养并为超过13只猫找到了家。结果被印成了我有13只猫。我花了好几年才纠正过来。它在维基百科上挂了很久。每次我接受采访，有人
would say, tell me about your 13 cats. I don't feel like can we please. I fostered 13 cats. And not at the same time, like one by one. Right, over years. Well, incidentally, kitten rescue is where I adopted Sunny. And I'm going to link to them in our show notes. They are such a great organization. And I also have some really fun photos of Dunder and Mifflin from when they were kittens, as well as now, and we'll put it in our Instagram stories. Oh, I can't wait. You guys, as Jenna was sharing the story, I just was remembering all these memories. And when we would walk onto set, there were these side doors that we would come onto the set of the Dunder Mifflin bullpen from our trailers. We had a wall of like announcements.
就会说，跟我说说你的13只猫吧。我心想，能不能请你们。我寄养了13只猫。而且不是同时，是一只接一只。对，多年来。顺便说一句，猫咪救援组织就是我收养桑尼的地方。我会在我们的节目笔记中链接到他们。他们是一个很棒的组织。我还有一些关于邓德和米夫林小时候以及现在的非常有趣的照片，我们会把它们放在我们的Instagram故事里。哦，我等不及了。伙计们，当珍娜分享这个故事时，我一直在回忆这些记忆。当我们走进片场时，有侧门可以从我们的拖车进入邓德·米夫林办公室的片场。我们有一面墙贴满了公告。
Like if someone had a baby, we'd put the photo up there or, you know, just any little thing. I remember like when you were in a poker tournament, like we put a little thing up there, just anything that was going on in our lives, cast and crew. And then you would walk by and you would read and you'd be like, Oh my gosh, Patrick, you know, you're getting married. That's so great. There'd be little announcements. Well, there was a photo of Dunder and Mifflin. We had printed off a little flyer. Yeah, a little flyer that hung there. And we would walk past it every day and we left it up even after they were adopted, just like their photo. I love that. I want to see what they look like now. I know. They're so cute. Well, that's
比如如果有人生了孩子，我们会把照片贴在那里，或者，你知道，任何小事。我记得当你参加扑克锦标赛时，我们贴了一个小东西在那里，任何发生在我们生活中的事，演员和工作人员。然后你会走过去读，你会说，天哪，帕特里克，你知道，你要结婚了。那太棒了。会有一些小公告。好吧，有一张邓德和米夫林的照片。我们打印了一张小传单。是的，一张挂在那里的传单。我们每天都会走过它，即使在它们被收养后我们也把它留着，就像它们的照片一样。我喜欢这个。我想看看它们现在长什么样。我知道。它们太可爱了。好吧，这就是
all I've got. Should we take a break and then come back and yeah, let's get into this episode. There's so much fun stuff to discuss. This episode kicks off with a very exuberant Merry Christmas from Dwight and Jim, who, if you remember, are now the heads of the party planning committee. Yeah, they're still in charge of the parties. I have to say, they do a good job this year. They do. This is a great Christmas party. The decor is great. They have some great ideas. Well, I have a reason for that I'm going to share with you that was in deleted scenes. I can't wait. Well next up, Dwight has a talking head where he shares that he put his diabolical plan
我所有的内容了。我们要休息一下，然后回来，是的，让我们进入这一集。有很多有趣的事情要讨论。这一集以德怀特和吉姆非常热情的“圣诞快乐”开场，如果你还记得的话，他们现在是派对策划委员会的负责人。是的，他们仍然负责派对。我必须说，他们今年做得很好。确实。这是一个很棒的圣诞派对。装饰很棒。他们有一些很棒的想法。好吧，我有一个原因，我会在删除的场景中与你们分享。我等不及了。好吧，接下来，德怀特有一个谈话片段，他分享说他把他的恶魔计划
on hold. I have to share something. So when I was talking to Joya about this episode, she said, oh, Angela, I meant to reach out to you about Scott's Tots because we launched a diabolical blog to coincide with Dwight's diabolical plan. What? Yes. It was a weekly blog about Dwight's diabolical plan. You can still see the blog entries. I'm going to put a link to them in our stories. I'm showing Jenna a picture of what the front page looks like. Oh, it's the coup de Dwight, the diabolical blog by Dwight K. Schrute. So I'll put that in our stories, but I thought that was so fun. After this Dwight talking head, Jenna, there was a gym talking head that got deleted. It's in the extended producer's cut, but
搁置了。我必须分享一些事情。所以当我和乔亚谈论这一集时，她说，哦，安吉拉，我本来想联系你关于“斯科特的学童”那一集，因为我们推出了一个恶魔博客来配合德怀特的恶魔计划。什么？是的。这是一个关于德怀特恶魔计划的每周博客。你仍然可以看到博客条目。我会把链接放在我们的故事里。我正在给珍娜看主页的样子。哦，是“德怀特政变”，德怀特·K·舒鲁特的恶魔博客。所以我会在我们的故事里放上那个，但我认为那太有趣了。在这个德怀特谈话片段之后，珍娜，有一个吉姆的谈话片段被删除了。它在制片人加长剪辑版里，但我
I want to read to you a little bit of it from the shooting draft. Okay. It was actually really sweet. Jim says, lately there have been serious rumors that our company might go bankrupt. David Wallace asked me to keep morale high. Then there's B-roll. And the B-roll captures people taking turns going into Jim's office while Jim actually listens and jots down notes. Angela goes in, Kevin, Kelly, Stanley, Jim's talking head continues. I asked around what people wanted with Christmas. Get creative, I said. And people weren't really creative exactly. They said secret Santa karaoke food, pretty much what we usually have, which is great. Then there's B-roll of Jim and Dwight dusting off old decorations. Jim continues
想从拍摄草稿中读一点给你听。好的。它实际上真的很甜蜜。吉姆说，最近有严重的传言说我们公司可能会破产。大卫·华莱士让我保持士气高昂。然后是B-roll（辅助镜头）。B-roll捕捉到人们轮流进入吉姆的办公室，而吉姆实际上在倾听并记下笔记。安吉拉进去了，凯文、凯利、斯坦利，吉姆的谈话片段继续。我问大家圣诞节想要什么。我说，发挥创意。人们并不是真的很有创意。他们说秘密圣诞老人、卡拉OK、食物，基本上就是我们通常有的，这很棒。然后是吉姆和德怀特清理旧装饰的B-roll。吉姆继续
to talk. People usually argue about food. So I told everyone to bring their favorites. Then there's B-roll Angela laying out carrots and celery. Kevin with an enormous chocolate cake. Pam brings in a lasagna and finally creed emptying a large can of beans into a glass serving bowl. Jim continues. I made a very organized sign up sheet for karaoke so there's no fighting. B-roll of Jim holding up a clipboard next to the karaoke machine with a must take turns written on it in red letters. Kelly, Andy and Kevin crowd around to sign up. Jim continues talking. And no crying. Jim hangs up a banner in the conference room. It says Merry Christmas. Santa hates tears. And then lastly, Jim says, I made Phyllis Santa fulfilling
说话。人们通常会为食物争论。所以我告诉每个人带他们最喜欢的。然后是安吉拉摆放胡萝卜和芹菜的B-roll。凯文拿着一个巨大的巧克力蛋糕。帕姆带了千层面，最后克里德把一大罐豆子倒进玻璃碗里。吉姆继续。我为卡拉OK做了一张非常有组织的报名表，这样就不会有争吵了。吉姆拿着剪贴板站在卡拉OK机旁，上面用红字写着“必须轮流”。凯利、安迪和凯文挤在一起报名。吉姆继续说。而且没有哭泣。吉姆在会议室挂了一条横幅。上面写着“圣诞快乐。圣诞老人讨厌眼泪。”最后，吉姆说，我让菲利斯扮演圣诞老人，实现了
a lifelong dream. Phyllis hugs Jim and will not let go. Jim tries to subtly break free. And then Jim ends this talking head with this. I'm doing a good job, I think, because this year I care. I know it's weird. He shrugs happy. That is so sweet. I know it was a great talking head and it really showed how Jim was invested in making this a good party. This is good management. This just reminds me of how Greg Daniels would treat us. He would come around and he would say, what do you think should happen to your character this year? Yes. And you'd be like, I have ideas. Thank you for asking. So now Erin is going to make an announcement to the bullpen. She is pleading with whoever is her secret
她一生的梦想。菲利斯拥抱吉姆，不肯放手。吉姆试图巧妙地挣脱。然后吉姆以这个结束了谈话片段。我想我做得很好，因为今年我在乎。我知道这很奇怪。他耸耸肩，很开心。那太甜蜜了。我知道这是一个很棒的谈话片段，它真正展示了吉姆是如何投入到让这个派对变得美好的。这是很好的管理。这让我想起格雷格·丹尼尔斯是如何对待我们的。他会走过来问，你认为今年你的角色应该发生什么？是的。你会说，我有想法。谢谢你的询问。所以现在艾琳要向办公室宣布一件事。她恳求她的秘密
Santa to please stop sending gifts. Her secret Santa is doing a 12 days of Christmas themed gift for her. And she says that her cat killed the turtle dove. The French hens are making a nest in her hair. She has scratches down her face. She's having a hard time with this gift. Oh my gosh, she seems really miserable. Well, I wanted to share with you guys that the DVD commentary for this episode is Ellie Kemper, Mindy Kaling and Claire Scanlon. Oh, great. Yeah. And they talked a little bit about this scratch on Ellie's face. Mindy shared that they had a test model that they did a few different types of scratches on and took pictures of and then Mindy had to pick which scratch she liked. Yes. Randy said our
圣诞老人请停止送礼物。她的秘密圣诞老人正在为她做一份以“圣诞节的十二天”为主题的礼物。她说她的猫杀死了斑鸠。法国母鸡在她的头发里筑巢。她的脸上被抓伤了。她在这个礼物上遇到了困难。天哪，她看起来真的很痛苦。好吧，我想告诉你们，这一集的DVD评论是艾莉·坎伯、敏迪·卡灵和克莱尔·斯坎伦。哦，太棒了。是的。她们谈到了艾莉脸上的那道抓痕。敏迪分享说，她们有一个测试模型，做了几种不同类型的抓痕并拍了照片，然后敏迪必须选择她喜欢的抓痕。是的。兰迪说我们的
makeup artist Laverne created the effects of the scratch. And I guess Randall and Paul both were really pleased with the first try. And that's the one they picked. And he said Laverne's team was masterful at executing this gag. Well, we had a fan catch during this scene at reception from Ursula N in Toledo, Ohio, who says at two minutes and 33 seconds, there is a card on Aaron's desk. Is that card the one where Michael photoshopped himself into Carol's family ski trip back in season three because it looks just like it? I assumed it didn't on it. It absolutely looks like it. I think it is. I think Michael is still setting that card out. That is brilliant and perfect. I also caught a card taped to the
化妆师拉弗恩创造了抓痕的效果。我想兰德尔和保罗对第一次尝试都很满意。那就是他们选择的那一个。他说拉弗恩的团队在执行这个恶作剧方面非常精湛。好吧，我们在前台这一幕中收到了来自俄亥俄州托莱多的厄休拉·N的粉丝捕捉，她说在2分33秒，艾琳的桌子上有一张卡片。那张卡片是迈克尔在第三季把自己的照片PS进卡罗尔家庭滑雪旅行的那张吗？因为它看起来一模一样。我假设它就是。它看起来绝对是。我想是的。我想迈克尔仍然把那张卡片放在那里。这太聪明、太完美了。我还捕捉到一张卡片贴在
front of reception. And it was a Christmas card that me and Brian and Oscar made and gave to everyone. Oh my gosh. I remember you guys used to do an accountants card at Christmas. Yes. I would make them take a picture with me and character and we would give it to everyone. Well, Andy has a talking head where he begged Dwight and Jim to give him Aaron for Secret Santa. And he's the one who's giving out the 12 days of Christmas gifts. And he says, is it his fault that the first eight days amount to 30 birds? And during this talking head, you can see him trying to put little bow ties on some swans. You see Aaron go to her car and it's filled with geese. I asked Randy Cordray, how did we
前台的前面。那是一张我和布莱恩还有奥斯卡制作并送给每个人的圣诞卡。天哪。我记得你们过去在圣诞节会做一张会计部的卡片。是的。我会让他们和我一起拍角色照，然后我们会把它送给每个人。好吧，安迪有一个谈话片段，他恳求德怀特和吉姆让他抽到艾琳作为秘密圣诞老人。他是那个送出“圣诞节的十二天”礼物的人。他说，第一天的八天加起来有30只鸟是他的错吗？在这个谈话片段中，你可以看到他试图给一些天鹅系上小领结。你看到艾琳去她的车里，里面装满了鹅。我问兰迪·科德雷，我们是如何
pull off these shots with the geese and the swans? He said, once again, we use Bob Dunn's Animal Rentals in Silmar, California. We needed seven swans in the lobby and they required three days of prep and rehearsal. He said swans can be very aggressive toward people that they don't know. Oh yeah. So the extra days of prep were to just let them walk around this lobby area and meet Ed Helms. And lady, I remember one day at lunch, Ed was eating like really fast and he said he had to finish eating quickly because he had to go spend time with the swans. Oh my gosh, I don't doubt it. They had to get to know him. I was once chased by a very aggressive duck. In Indonesia, they would use like ducks and stuff to protect
完成这些有鹅和天鹅的镜头的？他说，我们再次使用了加州西尔马的鲍勃·邓恩动物租赁公司。我们需要大厅里有七只天鹅，它们需要三天的准备和排练。他说天鹅对不认识的人会非常有攻击性。哦，是的。所以额外的准备时间只是为了让它们在那个大厅区域走动并认识艾德·赫尔姆斯。而且，女士，我记得有一天午餐时，艾德吃得非常快，他说他必须快点吃完，因为他得去和天鹅待在一起。天哪，我不怀疑。它们必须认识他。我曾经被一只非常有攻击性的鸭子追赶。在印度尼西亚，他们会用鸭子之类的东西来保护
like a guard duck. Yeah, like a guard duck. And I was on a walk. It was up in the mountains and I was like probably like 11 and this duck like chased me. I was terrified. I was like, oh my God, they're scary. Yeah. I mean, they'll come for you. They'll come for you. Well, the six geese that were in Aaron's car also had to do three days of prep. We had three trainers each day to wrangle all the birds. They created a fenced in area in our warehouse. That's where they would stay. It was very cool and dark. I guess they like that. Randy said that the total cost for the four days of birds and trainers was $9,603. Now we also got a fan question from Liam D in Ireland who said he loves the storyline where Andy
比如看门鸭。是的，就像看门鸭。我当时在散步。那是在山上，我大概11岁，那只鸭子追我。我吓坏了。我心想，天哪，它们太可怕了。是的。我是说，它们会来找你的。它们会来找你的。好吧，艾琳车里的那六只鹅也必须进行三天的准备。我们每天有三名训练师来驯服所有的鸟。它们在我们的仓库里创造了一个围栏区域。那就是它们待的地方。非常凉爽和黑暗。我想它们喜欢那样。兰迪说，四天鸟类和训练师的总费用是9603美元。现在我们还收到了来自爱尔兰的利亚姆·D的粉丝提问，他说他喜欢安迪
gives Aaron the 12 days of Christmas. And he said, did you know that in 1982 there was a record by an Irish actor and comedian named Frank Kelly called Christmas Countdown where he recalls all of the gifts in the 12 days of Christmas song. It's basically the same idea. Someone is sending them gifts for the 12 days of Christmas. It ends up just as bad for him as it did for Aaron. He said this song was a chart hit in Ireland, Australia and the UK. I have an audio clip. Oh, I want to hear it. Okay, so I think he's so right though. He said they've gone completely savage. Oh, We cannot use the bathroom now because they have gone completely savage
给艾琳送“圣诞节的十二天”的故事情节。他说，你知道吗，1982年有一张由爱尔兰演员兼喜剧演员弗兰克·凯利录制的唱片，叫《圣诞倒计时》，他在里面回忆了“圣诞节的十二天”歌曲中的所有礼物。基本上是同一个主意。有人在圣诞节的十二天里给他们送礼物。结果对他来说和对艾琳一样糟糕。他说这首歌在爱尔兰、澳大利亚和英国都登上了排行榜。我有一个音频片段。哦，我想听听。好的，但我认为他说得太对了。他说它们已经完全变得野蛮了。哦，我们现在不能用浴室了，因为它们已经完全变得野蛮了
and rush the door every time we try to enter. If things go on this way, the mother and I will smell as bad as the living room carpet. Please lay off. It is not fair." Okay, so. He's so right though when he said they've gone completely savage. I know. So it's just very funny. He's just earnestly writing these letters to Nora to like, please stop after every gift. They did enjoy the five golden rings. He was like, okay, that was a nice touch, but otherwise the birds are destroying this house. That is so fun. I want to hear the whole thing. Well, maybe we can put a link. I found it on YouTube. We'll put it in stories. Now we have maybe one of the sweetest Phyllis talking heads. She's in full Santa outfit
而且每次我们试图进入时都会冲向门口。如果事情这样继续下去，我和母亲身上会和客厅地毯一样臭。请停下来。这不公平。”好的，所以。他说它们已经完全变得野蛮了，他说得太对了。我知道。所以这非常有趣。他只是真诚地在每份礼物后写信给诺拉，请她停下来。他们确实喜欢那五枚金戒指。他心想，好吧，那是个不错的点缀，但除此之外，鸟儿们正在摧毁这个房子。这太有趣了。我想听听完整版。好吧，也许我们可以放一个链接。我在YouTube上找到了。我们会把它放在故事里。现在我们有可能是最甜蜜的菲利斯谈话片段之一。她穿着全套圣诞老人服装
and she tears up. She says it's been a long journey, but she's finally Santa Claus. I was so moved by this. I know. This is Phyllis at her best. She does this thing where she's so deeply and realistically commits an earnest from the heart. Yes. And it just becomes something deeper than comedic. I love it. And then right after Creed's like, what if you've been really bad like bordering on evil? Yeah, what happened Santa? Well, we also get a little peek into Dwight's secret Santa gift. Someone has been sending him different pieces of a machine and he has been trying to put them together. This is so perfect for Dwight. Like talk about someone knowing Dwight and like giving him the perfect gift. Yes. Well, we get to see Pam with
并且流下了眼泪。她说这是一段漫长的旅程，但她终于成为了圣诞老人。我被这个深深打动了。我知道。这是菲利斯最好的状态。她做这件事时，是如此深刻、现实地投入到真诚的内心之中。是的。它变得比喜剧更深沉。我喜欢它。然后紧接着克里德说，如果你一直很坏，甚至接近邪恶怎么办？是的，圣诞老人怎么了？好吧，我们还窥探了德怀特的秘密圣诞老人礼物。有人一直在给他寄机器的不同部件，他一直在试图把它们组装起来。这对于德怀特来说太完美了。就像谈论一个了解德怀特并给他完美礼物的人。是的。好吧，我们看到了帕姆和
her famous lasagna, which is, you know, she just makes it from the box, Jenna. I know. I mean, people ask her, where did she get this recipe? It's from the box. She is just prattling on and Oscar is not paying attention. He's looking out the window at warehouse fella throwing the football. Pam clocks this and this is going to start her into matchmaker mode. I wanted to share two things about this scene, Angela. Number one, I can make lasagna from memory. So can I. And my family uses cottage cheese instead of ricotta cheese. It is, I don't know, maybe a Missouri thing. It's definitely a my family thing. It's so good. It's a milder cheese, especially for kids. Yeah. You know, I can layer it up. This was one of my three big meals that I learned how to make before I went
她著名的千层面，你知道，她只是从盒子里拿出来的，珍娜。我知道。我是说，人们问她，她从哪里得到的这个食谱？它是从盒子里来的。她只是在喋喋不休，而奥斯卡没有注意。他正看着窗外仓库里的家伙扔橄榄球。帕姆注意到了这一点，这将使她进入红娘模式。安吉拉，我想分享关于这一幕的两件事。第一，我可以凭记忆做千层面。我也是。而且我的家人用白干酪代替乳清干酪。这，我不知道，也许是密苏里州的特色。这绝对是我家人的特色。它太好吃了。这是一种更温和的奶酪，特别是对孩子来说。是的。你知道，我可以把它一层层铺好。这是我在去
off to college. We must have been in the same sort of mindset because I was like, oh, lasagna, I can eat off that for days. I'll learn how to make it. Anytime I had anyone over for dinner, lasagna, lasagna. The other thing I want to share is that I am wearing belly bump D. Oh, I have not talked about my belly bump in a while. I forgot to point out that in shareholder meeting in Scott's Tots, I was in belly bump C. And so now for this episode, I'm already in belly D, but here's the thing. According to the belly tracker, the banker, which is our next episode, was actually shot before Scott's Tots. Do you go down a size? I think I do because according to the tracker, the banker is belly C. So let's see next week, my belly might get smaller for a second.
上大学之前学会做的三顿大餐之一。我们一定有同样的心态，因为我心想，哦，千层面，我可以吃上好几天。我会学会怎么做。任何时候我有客人来吃晚饭，千层面，千层面。我想分享的另一件事是我戴着孕肚垫D。哦，我有一段时间没谈论我的孕肚垫了。我忘了指出，在“股东大会”和“斯科特的学童”中，我戴的是孕肚垫C。所以现在对于这一集，我已经戴上了孕肚垫D，但问题是，根据孕肚追踪器，“银行家”，也就是我们的下一集，实际上是在“斯科特的学童”之前拍摄的。你尺寸变小了吗？我想是的，因为根据追踪器，“银行家”是孕肚垫C。所以让我们看看下周，我的肚子可能会暂时变小。
Well, Michael is going to arrive dressed as Santa and Pam says we already have a Santa. Michael is so upset that Jim let Phyllis take over as Santa. Yeah, he says a woman. Where does it stop? He says, you can't believe it. But Jim will not budge. And then Michael says, you have to tell her she can't be Santa. Jim's like, I won't do that. He says, just do it anonymously. You can send her like a note, like ransom style with letters cut out. I have some in my drawer. How many ransom notes is he sending to people? Well, you know, nowadays you can just download a font for your computer. Ransom note font style. Yeah, Michael, you don't have to go cut all the letters out and put them in your drawer. But we know he's not using his computer much. We've
好吧，迈克尔要穿着圣诞老人装到达，帕姆说我们已经有圣诞老人了。迈克尔非常难过，吉姆让菲利斯接管了圣诞老人。是的，他说一个女人。这到哪里才是个头？他说，你简直不敢相信。但吉姆不会让步。然后迈克尔说，你必须告诉她她不能当圣诞老人。吉姆说，我不会那样做。他说，匿名做就行了。你可以给她写张纸条，比如勒索信风格，用剪下来的字母。我的抽屉里有一些。他到底给多少人发了勒索信？好吧，你知道，现在你可以直接为你的电脑下载一种字体。勒索信字体风格。是的，迈克尔，你不必去剪下所有的字母并把它们放在抽屉里。但我们知道他不太用电脑。我们已经
established that. No, it's just a place to put post-its. Well, Jenna, this starts a whole segment. I'm calling the dueling Santas. One of the best segments of all time. Of all time. Phyllis has a Santa photo op. Again, amazing setup by Jim and Dwight. I know. She's got the chair and the backdrop, the whole thing. Everyone is going to take their picture with Santa. Well, Michael's ticked off. He wants his own Santa photo op. Yeah. So he's going to set himself up in a chair right there across from reception. He wants to sit on his lap. Someone come sit on his lap. Well, I guess the first person to sit on Michael's lap is going to be Kevin. He's so excited. Kevin says he's never been able to do this before.
确定了这一点。不，那只是一个放便利贴的地方。好吧，珍娜，这开启了一个完整的片段。我称之为“决斗圣诞老人”。有史以来最好的片段之一。有史以来。菲利斯有一个圣诞老人拍照的机会。同样，吉姆和德怀特令人惊叹的设置。我知道。她有椅子和背景，整套东西。每个人都要和圣诞老人合影。好吧，迈克尔很生气。他想要他自己的圣诞老人拍照机会。是的。所以他要把自己安置在接待处对面的椅子上。他想让人坐在他的腿上。有人来坐在他的腿上。好吧，我想第一个坐在迈克尔腿上的人是凯文。他太兴奋了。凯文说他以前从来没能这样做过。
Yeah. So Kevin sits on Michael's lap. Michael's like, well, what would you like for Christmas, little boy? And Kevin's like, I don't know. I didn't know you were going to ask me that. And Michael's like, what did you think was going to happen? And Kevin's like, I don't know. No one's ever let me sit on their lap before. Michael's really struggling now. He's like, just tell me what toys you want. And Kevin's taken a long time to think about it. Clearly, Michael is uncomfortable. Yes. I found a quote from an Entertainment Weekly article from Mindy, where she says, quote, when Kevin unburdens himself on Michael's lap, Steve's voice changed to this distressed, guttural mumble showing the instantaneous agony he was in. This was literally a laugh out loud
是的。所以凯文坐在迈克尔的腿上。迈克尔说，好吧，小男孩，你圣诞节想要什么？凯文说，我不知道。我不知道你会问我这个。迈克尔说，你以为会发生什么？凯文说，我不知道。从来没有人让我坐在他们的腿上。迈克尔现在真的很挣扎。他说，只要告诉我你想要什么玩具。凯文花了好长时间才想出来。显然，迈克尔很不舒服。是的。我从敏迪的一篇《娱乐周刊》文章中找到了一句引语，她说，引用，“当凯文在迈克尔的腿上卸下负担时，史蒂夫的声音变成了这种痛苦的、喉音的嘟囔，显示出他瞬间的痛苦。”这简直是一个让人大笑的时刻。
moment because you can see me laughing in the background, completely breaking character. And then we got a fan question from Robbie Vee in South Korea, who said, at seven minutes, 56 seconds, if you pause, you can clearly see Ed Helms and Mindy Kalen breaking so hard. A few seconds later, BJ Novak started to break. They were all laughing so hard Ed needed to hide from the camera. Will you guys please share your stories about this scene? Jenna and Angela, were you also laughing during the scene? Oh my gosh. Oh Robbie. Robbie, I would say overwhelmingly, this was one time where the entire cast broke. The entire cast. I've read so many interviews in prepping for this episode where John, Ed, and Brian all talk about how they were all breaking.
时刻，因为你可以看到我在背景里大笑，完全出戏了。然后我们收到了来自韩国Robbie Vee的粉丝提问，他说在7分56秒，如果你暂停，可以清楚地看到Ed Helms和Mindy Kaling笑得非常厉害。几秒钟后，BJ Novak也开始笑场。他们都笑得太厉害了，Ed不得不躲开镜头。你们能分享一下关于这个场景的故事吗？Jenna和Angela，你们当时也在笑吗？天哪。哦，Robbie。Robbie，我可以说，绝大多数情况下，这是全体演员唯一一次集体笑场。全体演员。我在为这一集做准备时读了很多采访，John、Ed和Brian都谈到了他们当时是如何集体笑场的。
I read where Vada, our script supervisor, said how she would have to mark whenever someone laughed in a take and it was like everyone. They didn't have any footage of us not laughing. None of it. They didn't have any. We never got it. That's why all the footage shows us breaking in the background. That's exactly right. On the commentary, Claire Scanlon, who was our editor, talked about how difficult it was to edit the scene because someone was constantly laughing. And if you watch you guys all see Mindy break, Ed literally had to go behind the wall. Yeah. There was like a plant and a wall and you watch him go and hide. There are a lot of bloopers from this and you guys, I just felt like we had to hear them. Oh my gosh,
我读到我们的剧本主管Vada说，她必须标记出每个人在拍摄时笑场的时刻，几乎每个人都笑了。他们根本没有我们不笑的镜头。一个都没有。我们从来没拍到过。这就是为什么所有的镜头都显示我们在背景里笑场。完全正确。在评论音轨中，我们的剪辑师Claire Scanlon谈到了剪辑这个场景有多困难，因为总有人在笑。如果你仔细看，你们都会看到Mindy笑场了，Ed不得不躲到墙后面。是的。那里有一株植物和一堵墙，你可以看到他走过去躲起来。这个场景有很多NG镜头，伙计们，我觉得我们必须听听。天哪，
this is going to take me back. I can sit on your lap. You can sit on my lap all you want because I am a male Santa and that is something that Phyllis cannot do. Oh my god. Okay. This is really comfortable. Okay. Tell me what you want, little boy. Oh, I don't know. I didn't know you were going to ask me that. What did you think was going to happen? I didn't know. No one's ever let me sit on their lap before. Hurry up. Just say some toys. Can you give me some choices? Oh my god. Kevin, please. Sorry. John dives out of frame like we're all losing it. You notice in those scenes there are no like cutaways to the reverse. There are no reaction shots. No, they couldn't. There were the people who were like stationed behind this action and they had to try to hold it together.
这让我想起了过去。我可以坐在你的腿上。你可以随便坐在我的腿上，因为我是男圣诞老人，这是Phyllis做不到的。天哪。好吧。这真的很舒服。好吧。告诉我你想要什么，小男孩。哦，我不知道。我没想到你会问我这个。你以为会发生什么？我不知道。从来没有人让我坐在他们的腿上。快点。随便说几个玩具。你能给我几个选择吗？天哪。Kevin，拜托。抱歉。John跳出了画面，就像我们所有人都快疯了一样。你注意到在那些场景中没有反打镜头吗？没有反应镜头。没有，他们做不到。那些人被安排在动作后面，他们必须努力保持镇定。
The rest of us, we were all there. We're all watching. You don't see us because we couldn't ever act. No, we were just all laughing. That like took me back watching it and reading everyone's like stories from that day. It was so much fun. Well, Phyllis is mad. She demands that Jim take care of this double Santa situation. Otherwise, she's going to have to get Bob involved. Yeah. And Jim is like, what? And then she goes, never mind. I shouldn't have said that. Oh my god. What is Bob up to? I don't know. Erin is going to jokingly ask Andy if he's her secret Santa. And he jokingly admits that he is. Yeah. This is very similar to what happened in Murder. Right. Where they're jokingly asking each other on a date. This is a downfall of their relationship.
我们其他人都在那里。我们都在看。你看不到我们，因为我们根本无法演戏。不，我们只是都在笑。看着它并读到每个人关于那一天的故事，让我回到了过去。太有趣了。好吧，Phyllis生气了。她要求Jim处理这个双重圣诞老人的情况。否则，她就得让Bob介入了。是的。Jim说，什么？然后她说，算了。我不该说那个。天哪。Bob在搞什么？我不知道。Erin开玩笑地问Andy他是不是她的秘密圣诞老人。他开玩笑地承认他是。是的。这和《谋杀》那一集发生的事情非常相似。对吧。他们开玩笑地约对方出去。这是他们关系的低谷。
Where they don't just come out and say what they're thinking. No one's just straight up. Right. I don't know if you notice, but at seven minutes, 15 seconds, the golf picture is still on the wall. I did notice. I'll have you know the week that we shot Secret Santa is the same week that Mafia aired. So now that Mafia has aired, we have 100% committed to cutting out the storyline where Erin destroys the watercolor. I'm telling you, that is how last minute that decision was. How long that fight was. Could you imagine if the show ended and it was just a golf picture there? I cannot. And we just walk out and the last shot is a golf picture. No. No. Tragedy. Tragedy. Hope in a frame. Hope in a frame people.
他们没有直接说出自己的想法。没有人直截了当。对吧。我不知道你有没有注意到，在7分15秒，高尔夫球画还在墙上。我注意到了。我得告诉你，我们拍摄《秘密圣诞老人》的那一周正是《黑手党》播出的那一周。所以现在《黑手党》已经播出了，我们百分之百决定剪掉Erin毁掉水彩画的情节。我告诉你，那个决定是多么临时。那场戏有多长。你能想象如果剧集结束时墙上只是一幅高尔夫球画吗？我无法想象。我们走出去，最后一个镜头是一幅高尔夫球画。不。不。悲剧。悲剧。画框里的希望。画框里的希望，伙计们。
Well, Oscar's going to go down to the warehouse to hand out everyone's paychecks. There was a really fun scene in the shooting draft that didn't make it in where Oscar goes to Angela. She's about to go hand out the paychecks. That's who hands them out. I remember that. Yeah. And Oscar's like, wait, wait, wait, Angela, you know what? I'll go hand them out. And she's like, why? And he's like, oh, and it's like Oscar knows her so well. He's like, it's cold down there. He lists all these things. And she's like, okay, fine. And lets him go hand out the checks. But he's looking for Matt. But Matt's not there. He's out on a delivery. And Daryl's like, I'll take it. I'll give it to him. And Oscar's like, no, no, I can, I can wait.
好吧，Oscar要下到仓库去分发大家的工资支票。拍摄草稿中有一个非常有趣的场景没有被采用，Oscar去找Angela。她正要分发支票。那是她负责的工作。我记得那个。是的。Oscar说，等等，等等，Angela，你知道吗？我去分发吧。她说，为什么？他说，哦，Oscar太了解她了。他说，下面很冷。他列举了所有这些原因。她说，好吧，好吧。让她去分发支票。但他是在找Matt。但Matt不在。他出去送货了。Daryl说，我来拿吧。我会给他的。Oscar说，不，不，我可以，我可以等。
Yeah. Daryl's on to him. Oh yeah. Have you ever done something like this? Of course, we all have. I remember when I was like younger, like a kid, I had a little bit of a crush on one of the boys in my neighborhood. And I used to look out the window. And when I would see him outside like playing soccer or something, I would conveniently need to go to the mailbox. Yeah. Hoping, hoping that he would like wave at me or something, that we could have a run in. It never happened. I mean, in college, I watched Bassmasters because the guy I liked was really into watching Bassmasters, watching people fish and talk about the hooks they used and the lures and the what not. These are the things you do. Yeah. When you have a crush. Yeah. When all of a sudden this guy
是的。Daryl看穿了他。哦，是的。你做过这样的事吗？当然，我们都做过。我记得我小时候，对邻居里的一个男孩有点好感。我经常往窗外看。当我看到他在外面踢足球什么的，我就会找借口去邮箱。是的。希望，希望他能对我挥手什么的，我们能偶遇。从来没发生过。我的意思是，在大学里，我看了《鲈鱼大师赛》，因为我喜欢的那个男生非常喜欢看《鲈鱼大师赛》，看人们钓鱼，谈论他们用的鱼钩、鱼饵之类的东西。这就是你做的事情。是的。当你暗恋某人时。是的。当突然这个家伙
is like, I think on Sunday, I'm going to watch Bassmasters. I'm like, oh yeah, it's so great. That guy, the host, he is hilarious. And then you're like, who is the host? There is no host of Bassmasters. What is Bassmasters? And you couldn't Google back then because it was just invented. I know. Yeah. It wasn't invented yet. There was no internet. I will never let that one go. I know. It's too fun. Clearly. It's too fun. It's one of my favorite bits now. Well, Michael is still sitting in the chair upstairs trying to get people to sit on his lap. He is now like wrestling Ryan onto his lap while saying, I need this. I need this. Claire and Mindy also talked in the commentary that when Jim steps in and is like, hey,
说，我想周日我要看《鲈鱼大师赛》。我说，哦，太棒了。那个主持人，他太搞笑了。然后你会想，主持人是谁？《鲈鱼大师赛》根本没有主持人。什么是《鲈鱼大师赛》？那时候你还不能谷歌，因为它才刚发明。我知道。是的。还没发明呢。没有互联网。我永远不会放过那个梗。我知道。太有趣了。显然。太有趣了。这是我现在最喜欢的桥段之一。好吧，Michael还在楼上的椅子上坐着，试图让人们坐在他的腿上。他现在正把Ryan强行拉到他的腿上，同时说，我需要这个。我需要这个。Claire和Mindy在评论音轨中也谈到，当Jim介入并说，嘿，
you know, Michael, you can't, you know, you can't grab someone in the office and say, I need this while forcing them onto your lap. It makes me laugh out loud every time John's delivery is so good. They shared on the commentary that he kept laughing and so many takes. That's the thing. Like when you know something is funny, even though you have to deliver it, it like it tickles you while you're doing it. Yes. This scene is going to end with Michael putting his Santa hat into the punch bowl and storming out. So rude. Mindy talked about something in the commentary I thought was really interesting. She said at eight minutes 39 seconds when Michael makes his big announcement that he wants a vote on who is the true Santa. Mindy said, and I'm quoting
你知道，Michael，你不能，你知道，你不能在办公室里抓住某人并说，我需要这个，同时强迫他们坐在你的腿上。每次John的台词表现都让我大笑出声。他们在评论音轨中分享说，他一直在笑，拍了很多次。就是这样。当你明知某件事很好笑，即使你必须把它演出来，它也会在你表演时让你发痒。是的。这个场景将以Michael把他的圣诞帽扔进潘趣酒碗并冲出去而结束。太粗鲁了。Mindy在评论音轨中谈到了一件我认为非常有趣的事情。她说在8分39秒，当Michael宣布他想要投票选出谁是真正的圣诞老人时。Mindy说，我引用
her. One of the great legacies of the show is the announcements outside of Michael's office. She goes on to say, I used to call it act break alley. The writers would have Michael come out of his office, make an announcement, and that would often lead to the act break. And that's exactly what happens here. It's true. So you got a little act break alley there. Dwight is convinced that his secret Santa is sending him pieces of a gun. But this last piece doesn't make any sense. Why did they send him a dial? They should have sent him a trigger. And Meredith and Phyllis are like, why do you think it's a gun? And then Stanley has a great line where he says, unless the missing piece is a gun, you don't have a gun. I don't know why that tickles me so much.
她的话。这部剧最伟大的遗产之一就是Michael办公室外的公告。她接着说，我过去称之为“幕间休息巷”。编剧们会让Michael走出办公室，发布公告，这通常会导致幕间休息。这正是这里发生的事情。是真的。所以你那里有一个小小的“幕间休息巷”。Dwight确信他的秘密圣诞老人正在给他寄枪的零件。但最后这一块根本说不通。他们为什么要给他寄一个刻度盘？他们应该寄给他一个扳机。Meredith和Phyllis说，你为什么觉得那是枪？然后Stanley有一句很棒的台词，他说，除非缺失的部分是枪，否则你根本没有枪。我不知道为什么那让我觉得那么好笑。
His delivery was so good. We got a fan question from Beth G in Olympia, Washington. Who came up with the list of Dwight's speculations on what his Christmas present might be as he builds it? He has that piece of paper with the list. And Beth said, I never noticed that speculum was on the list. But during a recent rewatch, I noticed an almost died laughing. So I found a list of all the things that Dwight thinks. This is what's on his piece of paper. And answer to your question, Beth, this would be the writers. The writers would have come up with this list. Phil Shea would have gone to the writers and said, what do you want me to write on this piece of paper for Dwight? Right. And he would have had to write this list over and over
他的台词表现太棒了。我们收到了来自华盛顿州奥林匹亚市Beth G的粉丝提问。是谁想出了Dwight在组装礼物时猜测那是什么的清单？他有那张写着清单的纸。Beth说，我从来没注意到清单上有“窥镜”。但在最近的一次重温中，我注意到了，差点笑死。所以我找到了Dwight认为的所有东西的清单。这就是他纸上写的内容。回答你的问题，Beth，这应该是编剧们想出来的。编剧们会想出这个清单。Phil Shea会去找编剧说，你们想让我在这张纸上为Dwight写什么？对吧。他必须在各种纸垫上一遍又一遍地写这个清单，
and over and over again on various pads of paper because every take rain was going to scratch one out. So here was the list of things that Dwight thought this might be. An aardvark trap, beaver trap, gun, chipmunk trap, possum trap, skunk trap, lobster trap, man trap, lathe, abdominizer, speculum. He was mostly convinced it was some sort of trap, an animal trap. Santa Phyllis is now going to do the tree lighting reveal. And it's so festive and cheery. I love Phyllis in this scene. I know. I absolutely love it. Michael is starting to get real sour. Oh yeah. So he has this talking head where he says, I don't need a lot for Christmas like diamonds or brooch pendants. He just wants to be Santa. And this whole time he is like
因为每一条拍摄时Rain都要划掉一个。所以这是Dwight认为这可能是的东西的清单：食蚁兽陷阱、海狸陷阱、枪、花栗鼠陷阱、负鼠陷阱、臭鼬陷阱、龙虾陷阱、捕人陷阱、车床、腹肌训练器、窥镜。他大多确信这是一种陷阱，一种动物陷阱。圣诞老人Phyllis现在要进行点灯仪式了。这太喜庆、太欢快了。我喜欢这个场景里的Phyllis。我知道。我非常喜欢。Michael开始变得非常酸溜溜的。哦，是的。所以他有一个采访，他说，我不需要圣诞节有很多东西，比如钻石或胸针吊坠。他只是想当圣诞老人。而这段时间他一直在
reversing his Santa costume. Taking this decorative Christmas rope off his credenza, making it into a belt. I want to give a shout out to Steve's skills right here. I put it in my document. I need everyone to appreciate how hard this is to do. Yes. I wrote it too. I put two little stars by it. I said go to nine minutes, 52 seconds. Michael goes from Santa to Jesus and Steve had to do all the dialogue, changes outfit, put the belt on in one shot. There are no cutaways. This is truly amazing. I cannot express to you how hard it is to do even ordinary business while you're acting. How many times would I have to do a scene where I'm supposed to walk in with
反转他的圣诞老人服装。从他的餐具柜上取下装饰性的圣诞绳子，把它做成腰带。我想在这里为Steve的技巧点赞。我把它写在我的文档里了。我需要每个人都欣赏一下这有多难做到。是的。我也写了。我给它加了两颗小星星。我说去9分52秒。Michael从圣诞老人变成了耶稣，Steve必须在一次拍摄中完成所有的对话、更换服装、系上腰带。没有切镜头。这真是太神奇了。我无法向你表达在表演时做日常琐事有多难。我必须拍多少次场景，我被要求带着
a bag of groceries, set it down and take some items out of the bag? Suddenly I am incapable of doing that action. I multitask in my kitchen constantly. And I'm always thinking about it too. Like as I'm like shutting the fridge with my foot while scrambling an egg and drinking coffee and like organizing some homework papers in the morning and holding a conversation, I think to myself, if this was written out for me, I could never do it. I don't know what it is. It's so hard just to memorize your lines and say them truthfully. This amount of business is people should study it. He does such a good job. And with comic timing. I know. I always think of this when I would watch shows like ER or Grey's Anatomy,
一袋杂货走进来，放下它，然后从袋子里拿出一些东西？突然之间，我无法完成那个动作。我在厨房里不断地进行多任务处理。而且我总是想着它。就像我一边用脚关冰箱，一边炒鸡蛋，喝咖啡，早上整理一些家庭作业，同时还在进行对话，我对自己想，如果这是为我写的，我永远做不到。我不知道为什么。仅仅是记住台词并真实地说出来就很难了。这种业务量，人们应该研究一下。他做得太好了。而且还有喜剧节奏。我知道。我总是想到这一点，当我观看像《急诊室的故事》或《实习医生格蕾》这样的剧集时，
when they have the gurney flying through the hallway and they're yelling out all of this medical jargon, like, stay give me this gossip. And they're like having to do all this action. I'm like, well, that'll be a job I never have because that's a lot of talking and moving at the same time. Yeah. I won't be able to do it. Lots of business is hard to do. Lots of business. Because then also you have to like match it. Yeah, every time. We were both very impressed. We were. We were also cast on the perfect show because we often didn't have to do a lot of business. We were just at our deaths. True. Michael returns to the bullpen now. He's Jesus Christ. Angela applauds. She's the only one applauding. I mean, finally, as far as she's concerned.
当他们有担架飞过走廊，他们大喊着所有这些医学术语，比如，给我这个，给我那个。他们必须做所有这些动作。我想，好吧，那将是我永远不会从事的工作，因为同时说话和移动太多了。是的。我做不到。大量的业务很难做。大量的业务。因为然后你还必须匹配它。是的，每次。我们俩都印象深刻。我们是。我们也是完美剧集里的演员，因为我们通常不需要做很多业务。我们只是坐在桌子旁。真的。Michael现在回到办公区。他是耶稣基督。Angela鼓掌。她是唯一一个鼓掌的人。我的意思是，就她而言，终于。
Right. Finally, we have a real Christmas party. I went to the script to see if me applauding was written in the script. It was. It says Angela claps. Well, lady, I think we should take a break. But before we do, I just want to quickly bring up this moment in the break room where Andy has asked Phyllis, please do not tell Erin. I'm her secret Santa. And she says, okay, I won't. I'll say it's Michael. Andy's like, great. Whatever Phyllis can throw Michael under the bus. She's like, I'm going for it. Well, listen, he deserves it. I know. I know. I know. All right, we'll take a break and be right back. We are back. Kelly and Erin are singing some Christmas carols.
对吧。终于，我们有了一个真正的圣诞派对。我查了剧本，看看我鼓掌是不是剧本里写的。确实是。上面写着“Angela鼓掌”。好吧，女士，我想我们应该休息一下。但在我们休息之前，我只想快速提一下休息室里的这个时刻，Andy要求Phyllis，请不要告诉Erin我是她的秘密圣诞老人。她说，好吧，我不会的。我会说是Michael。Andy说，太好了。无论Phyllis怎么把Michael推向火坑。她说，我要这么做。好吧，听着，他罪有应得。我知道。我知道。我知道。好吧，我们休息一下，马上回来。我们回来了。Kelly和Erin正在唱一些圣诞颂歌。
I want you guys to know there was a whole lot more singing that got cut out. Really? Oh, yeah. And while they're singing, Pam is going to ask Oscar if he's talked to Matt. And then she is going into full matchmaker mode and she is just going to talk up Oscar's pate. How many times do I say pate? You're so awkward. It's so cringy. Pam is just so delighted to be a matchmaker. I know it was really fun to play. We had a fan question from Robbie Vee in South Korea. Who played Matt from the warehouse? Guys, Matt was played by Sam Daly. In addition to the office, Sam has appeared on such shows as The Magicians and CIS, Heart of Dixie, and in recurring roles on Madam Secretary and The Undercovers.
我想让你们知道，还有很多唱歌的部分被剪掉了。真的吗？哦，是的。当她们唱歌时，Pam要问Oscar是否和Matt谈过。然后她进入了完全的媒人模式，她要大谈特谈Oscar的馅饼。我说了多少次馅饼？你太尴尬了。太令人尴尬了。Pam只是很高兴能当媒人。我知道这演起来真的很有趣。我们收到了来自韩国Robbie Vee的粉丝提问。谁扮演了仓库里的Matt？伙计们，Matt是由Sam Daly扮演的。除了《办公室》，Sam还出演过《魔法师》、《犯罪现场调查》、《南国医恋》等剧集，并在《国务卿女士》和《卧底》中担任常驻角色。
And most recently on Bull, he is also the son of actor Tim Daly. Oh my God. I was so excited when he was on set because I loved Wings. Loved Wings. I watched every episode. I even went to a taping, you guys. You did? Yes. I came out to LA to visit like years before I lived here, and I went to a taping of Wings. I did that same thing too. I came out. It was like a special workshop for people who were interested in the biz. It was through UCLA, I think, because we stayed on the campus and they took us all around. And one of the things we got to do was go to a live television taping. I was fascinated. I loved it. I was coming out to visit my friend's brother was going to college here and we came and visited him and he took us to a live taping. Crystal Bernard,
最近还在《庭审专家》中出演。他也是演员Tim Daly的儿子。天哪。当他在片场时我太兴奋了，因为我喜欢《插翅难飞》。喜欢《插翅难飞》。我看了每一集。我甚至去参加了一次录制，伙计们。你去了？是的。我在住在这里的前几年来到洛杉矶参观，我去参加了《插翅难飞》的录制。我也做了同样的事。我来了。那就像是一个为对这个行业感兴趣的人举办的特别研讨会。我想是通过加州大学洛杉矶分校，因为我们住在校园里，他们带我们到处参观。我们能做的事情之一就是去参加现场电视录制。我着迷了。我喜欢它。我来参观我朋友的兄弟，他在这里上大学，我们来拜访他，他带我们去看了现场录制。Crystal Bernard，
during an act break, you know, because it was like a four-camera show where you're in an audience and they would have like breaks, she came up with her guitar and sang a whole song and she was such a good singer. That is so sweet. You know, that's a nice cast. Yeah. When I did my taping of that 70s show, the entire cast after the show was over went out to the audience and signed autographs. And I mean, this was like year, like six or something. I was so impressed. Well, we were very excited to have Sam on set. We were. Sam did an interview with bleepamag.com. Angela, thank you for forwarding me this. They asked him if he gets recognized for being Matt on our show. And he said, yes, nine times out of 10. If he gets recognized, it's for having been on the office.
在幕间休息时，你知道，因为它是一个四机位节目，你在观众席里，他们会有休息时间，她带着她的吉他上来唱了一整首歌，她唱得真好。太贴心了。你知道，那是一个很好的剧组。是的。当我录制《70年代秀》时，整个剧组在节目结束后都走到观众席给观众签名。我的意思是，那已经是第六年左右了。我印象非常深刻。好吧，我们很高兴Sam在片场。我们是。Sam接受了bleepamag.com的采访。Angela，谢谢你转发给我。他们问他是否因为在我们的剧中扮演Matt而被认出来。他说，是的，十次有九次。如果他被认出来，那是因为他出演过《办公室》。
He also said, quote, it was the first show I'd seen every episode of when I went to work on it. I knew where to go in the office and who sat where and everything. It was such an incredible experience. It was supposed to be a tiny role, but it turned into a recurring guest spot for a few episodes. I'll never take that for granted. And being around all those other actors was a blessing. Sam, you were a blessing. You were so delightful. And he is going to be in two more episodes. We just really liked him so much. Well, Jen, I have two things to share about this scene. So we see Matt from the warehouse upstairs. Did you notice the other warehouse workers? Yes, I noticed Maj and all the guys are at this party. Well, there was a whole runner that was cut from the episode.
他还说，引用：“这是我工作之前看过每一集的第一个节目。我知道办公室里该去哪里，谁坐在哪里，等等。这是一次令人难以置信的经历。”这本应该是一个很小的角色，但它变成了一个持续几集的常驻客串角色。我永远不会认为这是理所当然的。能和所有那些演员在一起是一种福气。Sam，你是一种福气。你太令人愉快了。他还要再出演两集。我们真的很喜欢他。好吧，Jen，关于这个场景我有两件事要分享。所以我们看到仓库里的Matt在楼上。你注意到其他仓库工人了吗？是的，我注意到了Maj和所有人都参加了这个派对。好吧，剧集中剪掉了一整条线索。
It is in the extended producer's cut where Michael goes down to the warehouse and invites all of them up to the party. It does not go over well. Why? Jim is annoyed because he did not plan to feed that many people. Oh, I thought it was really cute because he was all of a sudden concerned about food. The rest of the office is grumpy because the warehouse workers start eating everything, kind of take over. Angela has a talking head where she says she can hardly pretend to like the people in the actual office, let alone all the extra people now. There is a scene in the conference room where we learn that Maj has a nickname Garfield. Oh, because she loves lasagna? Because she loves lasagna. And when she sees it, she has to eat it all. This results in a scene
它在制片人的加长剪辑版里，Michael下到仓库邀请他们所有人上来参加派对。结果不太好。为什么？Jim很恼火，因为他没打算喂那么多人。哦，我觉得这真的很可爱，因为他突然开始关心食物了。办公室的其他人都很暴躁，因为仓库工人们开始吃掉所有东西，有点接管了派对。Angela有一个采访，她说她几乎无法假装喜欢办公室里的人，更不用说现在所有这些额外的人了。会议室里有一个场景，我们了解到Maj有一个绰号叫“加菲猫”。哦，因为她喜欢千层面？因为她喜欢千层面。当她看到它时，她必须把它全部吃掉。这导致了一个场景，
where she eats the entire lasagna that Pam brought while the warehouse guys are chanting Garfield, Garfield, Garfield. Amazing. Yes, there were so many extra scenes of the warehouse people driving everyone in the bullpen crazy. The second thing I want to share is on the commentary, Mindy and Ellie talked about how when they met Sam Daly, who played Matt, they got so tickled because they thought Sam and Ellie looked a lot alike in real life. Like they could be brother and sister. Yes. So I did a side by side and I want to show you. All right, Jenna, look at this. I'll put it in stories. I see it. Oh my gosh. They definitely could be family. I know. So I guess this is something Ellie was tickled about Ellie and Mindy during the week of filming.
她吃掉了Pam带来的整个千层面，而仓库里的家伙们在喊“加菲猫，加菲猫，加菲猫”。太神奇了。是的，有太多仓库人员让办公区每个人都发疯的额外场景。我想分享的第二件事是，在评论音轨中，Mindy和Ellie谈到当她们见到扮演Matt的Sam Daly时，她们觉得非常有趣，因为她们认为Sam和Ellie在现实生活中长得很像。就像他们可能是兄妹一样。是的。所以我做了一个对比图，我想给你们看。好吧，Jenna，看这个。我会把它放在故事里。我看到了。天哪。他们绝对可以是家人。我知道。所以我猜这是Ellie在拍摄周期间觉得很有趣的事情，Ellie和Mindy。
Michael is very cranky. He has like sat down kind of in the very middle of the party with a microphone and he is narrating the gifts that are being handed out. Yeah, he's doing like snarky commentary. Yeah. Angela gets some fabric, some gray fabric. She is so touched. I know. This person really knew her well. Michael says now she can make another dress that goes past her feet. It is also during this snarky commentary that Michael reveals that Andy is Aaron's secret Santa. Oof. Oh man. Aaron does not look happy. Michael continues to spiral. So he calls David Wallace and he has one of my favorite lines. He says a woman has you slurped his role as Santa. That's right. He also says guess who I'm dressed as and I love David Wallace's response
Michael非常暴躁。他拿着麦克风坐在派对的正中间，他正在解说正在分发的礼物。是的，他在做刻薄的评论。是的。Angela得到了一些布料，一些灰色的布料。她非常感动。我知道。这个人真的很了解她。Michael说现在她可以再做一件拖到脚下的裙子了。也是在这个刻薄的评论期间，Michael透露Andy是Erin的秘密圣诞老人。哎呀。天哪。Erin看起来不高兴。Michael继续失控。所以他给David Wallace打电话，他有我最喜欢的台词之一。他说，一个女人已经抢走了他圣诞老人的角色。没错。他还说，猜猜我打扮成什么样，我喜欢David Wallace的反应，
because he says either you tell me or I'm hanging up. Like I'm not, I'm not guessing what you're dressed as. I'm not doing this now. Well, David said this is a really bad time and asked for Stephanie, his assistant to step off. Yes. And then Aaron also needs to get off the phone. Michael's like, have they always been here? David tells Michael that the company has a buyer and he and Alan are out of work. Like just, you know what? Everyone's going to be gone. Everyone. Michael hears that. Oh my gosh. He said, you know what? Earlier today, the office needed Santa. Then they needed another Santa. Then they needed Jesus. And now they need Michael and that's one suit Phyllis can't fit into. At 14 minutes 38 seconds,
因为他说，要么你告诉我，要么我就挂断。就像我不会，我不会猜你打扮成什么样。我现在不干这个。好吧，David说现在是非常糟糕的时间，并要求他的助手Stephanie离开。是的。然后Erin也需要挂断电话。Michael说，他们一直都在这里吗？David告诉Michael公司有买家，他和Alan失业了。就像，你知道吗？每个人都要走了。每个人。Michael听到了。天哪。他说，你知道吗？今天早些时候，办公室需要圣诞老人。然后他们需要另一个圣诞老人。然后他们需要耶稣。现在他们需要Michael，那是Phyllis穿不进的一套西装。在14分38秒，
I'd like to point out a snow alert. There is now. Do we have a snow alert? We have a snow alert. There is some snow falling gently behind Michael out his window. It's evening now and it's begun snowing. This will be important later. Well, the way you solve any crisis is you buy pizza, lots of it. Michael's going to send Dwight with his password. You know, you have fun at the uh, uh, uh, uh. Yeah. So his pin is 9622. That is YMCA. The candy bag had some really fun alternates for what Michael's pin number might be. Oh yeah. Here's the first one. I don't want to say it, but it's the year everyone was scared by Y2K. Here's another one. I don't want to say it, but it's the year we partied like it's 1999.
我想指出一个雪警报。现在有了。我们有雪警报吗？我们有雪警报。Michael窗外正轻轻飘落着雪。现在是晚上了，开始下雪了。这在后面很重要。好吧，解决任何危机的方法就是买披萨，买很多。Michael要派Dwight去用他的密码。你知道，你在那个，那个，那个，那个玩得开心。是的，所以他的密码是9622。那是YMCA。糖果袋里有一些非常有趣的Michael密码备选方案。哦，是的。这是第一个。我不想说，但那是每个人都被千年虫吓坏的那一年。这是另一个。我不想说，但那是我们像1999年一样狂欢的那一年。
Here's another one. I don't want to say it, but it's the first line in a famous song about the alphabet. And then this was my favorite. When Dwight says, what is your pin? Michael was going to say 938562087116689473. I was just going to be like this ridiculously long number. Those were all of our candy bag must shoot alternates for this. And we stayed with the the shooting draft scripted YMCA. Erin's going to ask Andy, what was he thinking giving her all of those gifts? But you know what? Andy's not going to give up. He's not going to throw in the towel. No, he's not. And later on, I'm glad he didn't. Michael addresses the group. He's got the pizza. It's sitting there. I think we'd all like to eat it. But of course, Michael has to
这是另一个。我不想说，但那是一首关于字母表的著名歌曲的第一句。然后这是我最喜欢的。当Dwight说，你的密码是什么？Michael本来要说938562087116689473。我本来要说这个荒谬的长数字。那些都是我们糖果袋必须拍摄的备选方案。我们保留了拍摄草稿中剧本写的YMCA。Erin要问Andy，他送她所有那些礼物是在想什么？但你知道吗？Andy不会放弃。他不会认输。不，他不会。后来，我很高兴他没有。Michael向大家讲话。他有披萨。它就在那里。我想我们都想吃它。但当然，Michael必须
give a big speech first. And then he does what only Michael can do, which is he tells everybody the news that he was supposed to keep to himself, which is that we're going out of business. Well, everyone has a pretty strong reaction to this news. Dwight goes out and kicks the Christmas tree down. Yeah. Ellie and Mindy shared on the commentary that the day we shot this scene when Dwight's kicking the tree down, the episode Niagara was airing that evening. And everyone wanted to rap so we could get to Greg's to watch Niagara. I guess Greg had invited the whole cast over for a viewing party. So I dug in my digital clutter and I found the email invite. Oh my gosh, I totally remember this viewing party, by the way. Yeah. He says, Hey guys, please come to my house
先发表一个大演讲。然后他做了只有Michael能做的事，那就是他告诉大家他本应保密的消息，那就是我们要倒闭了。好吧，每个人对这个消息都有很强烈的反应。Dwight走出去把圣诞树踢倒了。是的。Ellie和Mindy在评论音轨中分享说，我们拍摄这个场景的那天，那一集《尼亚加拉》正在当晚播出。每个人都想快点结束，这样我们就能去Greg家看《尼亚加拉》。我猜Greg邀请了整个剧组去参加观看派对。所以我翻了翻我的数字杂物，我找到了电子邮件邀请。天哪，顺便说一下，我完全记得这个观看派对。是的。他说，嘿，伙计们，请来我家
for a viewing party for Niagara at 730 October 8th. Dinner and we will watch Jim and Pam get married. Love, Greg. Well, he and his wife, Suzanne, threw this party that was almost like a wedding reception. They had little M&Ms printed with Jim and Pam and little napkins like you would get at a wedding. Yes, it was so sweet. They had amazing food. It was really fun. The tables had, you know, the little confetti you can sprinkle that had the little wedding bells. It was so cute. I totally remember going to that. I went with Lee. So just know while we were filming this conference room scene of Michael spilling the beans and Dwight kicking the tree, we were like, All right, let's get these lines so we can make it to Greg's. Greg and Suzanne were always so
参加10月8日7点30分的《尼亚加拉》观看派对。晚餐，我们将观看Jim和Pam结婚。爱你们的，Greg。好吧，他和他的妻子Suzanne举办了这个派对，几乎就像一场婚礼招待会。他们有印着Jim和Pam的小M&M巧克力豆，还有像婚礼上那样的小餐巾纸。是的，太贴心了。他们有很棒的食物。真的很有趣。桌子上有，你知道，你可以撒的那种小五彩纸屑，上面有小婚礼钟。太可爱了。我完全记得去参加那个。我和Lee一起去的。所以要知道，当我们拍摄Michael泄露消息和Dwight踢树的会议室场景时，我们就像，好吧，让我们搞定这些台词，这样我们就能赶上Greg的派对。Greg和Suzanne总是那么
generous. They invited us into their home many, many times over these nine years of doing the office. It was a really warm and personal touch. And it bonded us from the beginning. It was really cool. And they still are. Greg invited us all over for Sunday brunch and we all went. We did, just recently. Just recently. Well, Michael tells everyone, listen, I'll get David on the phone so he can explain things. And Jim's like, I don't think so, Michael. I've been trying to reach him all day and he's not taking my calls. And Michael is like, I know how to get a hold of him. Mm-hmm. He's proud of this. It's amazing. He knows where David's kids go to school. So first he calls the school, pretends to be their pediatrician,
慷慨。在这九年拍摄《办公室》的过程中，他们多次邀请我们去他们家。这是一种非常温暖和个人的触动。它从一开始就让我们团结在一起。真的很酷。他们现在仍然是。Greg邀请我们所有人去吃周日早午餐，我们都去了。我们去了，就在最近。就在最近。好吧，Michael告诉大家，听着，我会给David打电话，让他解释清楚。Jim说，我不这么认为，Michael。我整天都在联系他，他不接我的电话。Michael说，我知道怎么联系他。嗯哼。他为此感到自豪。太神奇了。他知道David的孩子在哪里上学。所以首先他给学校打电话，假装是他们的儿科医生，
then he gets patched through to David's secretary, and then he talks in his little girl voice. And pretends to be David's daughter. So of course, when David answers the phone, he's like, What's up, sweetie? Mm-hmm. Because David thinks it's his daughter who's at the pediatrician's office. Oh my God, Michael. I mean, it's kind of amazing. In Michael's office, we have, for the first time, the whole entire Dunder Mifflin bullpen and warehouse. Yes. All of us hovering over this speakerphone. David reveals, Michael, first of all, you were never supposed to tell everybody. But second of all, I wasn't talking about you. All of your jobs are safe. It's just this upper management. You would have thought the office won the Super Bowl. I know. Everyone goes nuts.
然后他被转接到David的秘书那里，然后他用他那小女孩的声音说话。并假装是David的女儿。所以当然，当David接电话时，他说，怎么了，甜心？嗯哼。因为David以为那是他在儿科医生办公室的女儿。天哪，Michael。我的意思是，这太神奇了。在Michael的办公室里，我们第一次有了整个Dunder Mifflin办公区和仓库的人。是的。我们所有人都围在这个免提电话旁。David透露，Michael，首先，你根本不应该告诉大家。但其次，我说的不是你。你们的工作都很安全。只是这个高层管理。你会以为办公室赢得了超级碗。我知道。每个人都疯了。
Michael jumps off his desk and does this crowd surfing move. Mindy shared on the commentary that that was Steve's idea, that he thought it would be really fun if Michael dove into the crowd. We had a fan question from Kyle T. in Houston, Texas, who said, did y'all have a safety meeting for Michael's crowd dive? By the way, I want you to know, Kyle wrote y'all. Of course he did. Kyle from Texas. That's right. From Houston. H-Town. Did y'all have a safety meeting for Michael's crowd dive? I appreciated that detail, by the way. We did have a safety meeting. Eric Solke was our stunt coordinator, and Randy Cordray told us that he gave everyone direction on how to catch Steve's dive and how to lower him down to the ground
Michael从桌子上跳下来，做了这个人群冲浪的动作。Mindy在评论音轨中分享说，那是Steve的主意，他认为如果Michael跳进人群会非常有趣。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州休斯顿Kyle T的粉丝提问，他说，你们为Michael的人群跳水举行过安全会议吗？顺便说一下，我想让你知道，Kyle写的是“y'all”。他当然写了。来自德克萨斯的Kyle。没错。来自休斯顿。H-Town。你们为Michael的人群跳水举行过安全会议吗？顺便说一下，我很欣赏那个细节。我们确实举行了安全会议。Eric Solke是我们的特技协调员，Randy Cordray告诉我们，他给了每个人关于如何接住Steve的跳水以及如何把他安全地降到地上的指导。
safely. We also dressed two stunt players as warehouse workers and added them into the crowd. Randy said these burly stunt dudes were the main individuals involved in catching and protecting Steve and keeping him from crashing to the floor. Yeah, it wasn't me. It wasn't like no. Me and Kate and you holding Steve up. Correct. Now, folks, it's time for some karaoke. Yeah. This is where Dwight is singing Boulevard of Broken Dreams by Green Day. Andy joins in in some perfect harmony. Boulevard of Broken Dreams is from Green Day's 2004 album American Idiot. So something that I know, because I'm friends with Billy Joe Armstrong, I cannot say it enough. She's blushing again. I'm just so tickled every time I can say that.
我们还让两名特技演员打扮成仓库工人，把他们加进人群中。Randy说，这些魁梧的特技演员是参与接住和保护Steve并防止他摔到地板上的主要人员。是的，那不是我。不像，不。我和Kate还有你扶着Steve。正确。现在，伙计们，是时候唱卡拉OK了。是的。这就是Dwight唱Green Day的《破碎梦想大道》的地方。Andy加入了完美的和声。《破碎梦想大道》来自Green Day 2004年的专辑《美国白痴》。所以，我知道一件事，因为我是Billy Joe Armstrong的朋友，我怎么说都不为过。她又脸红了。每次我能说出那句话，我都觉得很有趣。
She's blushing again. Is that Billy had seen the office, but he recently in 2019 did a big rewatch of the whole series. Oh, nice. And I asked him, when you did your rewatch, did you remember that you had given us permission to use this song? Here's what he had to say. I was binge watching the office for the first time. And I was watching that episode. And then all of a sudden, the song came on. And I was completely taken by surprise. And like, I think my face started to get red. And Andy, he started singing in harmonies, which was almost like them, because we do have a musical for American Idiot. And he sang the same exact harmony that's in the musical. So it was good. Well, I just love it that he was surprised
她又脸红了。是Billy看过《办公室》，但他最近在2019年对整个系列进行了大规模的重温。哦，不错。我问他，当你重温时，你记得你给了我们使用这首歌的许可吗？他是这么说的。我第一次狂看《办公室》。我正在看那一集。然后突然，那首歌响起了。我完全感到惊讶。而且，我想我的脸开始变红了。Andy，他开始唱和声，这几乎就像他们，因为我们确实有《美国白痴》的音乐剧。他唱了和音乐剧中一模一样的和声。所以这很好。好吧，我只是喜欢他在重温时被自己的歌吓了一跳。我知道那太贴心了。听着，我想我们需要听听这个。我想我们需要听听Dwight和Andy唱《破碎梦想大道》。哦，当然。我喜欢它。我喜欢听他们唱。我每天都能听他们唱。唱那首歌会让我快乐。Mindy在评论音轨中分享说，她绝对喜欢这个以非圣诞歌曲为背景的圣诞节汇集在一起的蒙太奇。是的。Jenna，我猜卡拉OK有一个音乐插曲，Ed和Rain必须在期间即兴表演。太搞笑了。它在制片人的加长剪辑版里。我们必须听听他们的即兴表演。我的意思是，我知道他们已经制作了《美国白痴》的音乐剧版本，但我是说如果你把它带回舞台，
by his own song during that rewatch. I know that's so sweet. Listen, I think we need to hear this. I think we need to hear Dwight and Andy singing Boulevard of Broken Dreams. Oh, for sure. I love it. I love hearing them. I could hear them do it like every day. It would make me happy singing that song. Mindy shared in the commentary that she absolutely loved this montage of Christmas kind of all coming together set to the backdrop of a non-Christmas song. Yes. And Jenna, I guess there was a musical interlude to the karaoke and Ed and Rain had to vamp during it. It's so funny. It's in the extended producer's cut. We have to hear their vamp. I mean, I know they already produce the musical version of American Idiot, but I'm saying if you bring it back to the stage,
你可能想加上这个。你可能想。这太棒了。我们都经历过。我们都为卡拉OK选过歌，然后有一个大的音乐插曲，你会想，我该怎么办？我有点在点头。我的意思是，Ed演得太棒了。好吧，现在有一堆人们享受圣诞节的场景。每个人都得到了对他们非常有意义的礼物。最后，Dwight要得到他礼物的最后一部分，并意识到这段时间他一直在制作一个胡桃夹子。是的，当然。这就像一个非常酷的胡桃夹子。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州大草原城Lacey L的粉丝提问。请，请告诉我关于Dwight的胡桃夹子。是谁想出来的？他们在哪里找到的？还是他们必须创造它？我一直在寻找
you might want to add this. You might want to. It's pretty great. We've all been there. We've all picked a song for karaoke, and then there's a big musical interlude, and you're like, what do I do? I'm kind of bobbing my head. I mean, Ed crushed it. Well, there are just a bunch of scenes now of people enjoying Christmas. Everyone's getting gifts that are really meaningful to them. And finally, Dwight is going to get the last piece of his gift and realizes this whole time he's been making a nutcracker. Yes, of course. It's like a really cool nutcracker. We had a fan question from Lacey L in Grand Prairie, Texas. Please, please tell me about Dwight's nutcracker. Who came up with it? Where did they find it? Or did they have to create it? I have been looking
它多年了。Lacey，我想的一样。我想，我能得到一个吗？好吧，Randy告诉我，这不在剧本的第一个拍摄草稿中。整个线索是后来加进去的，他相信是冷开场的大师Aaron Schur写了这个故事弧，因为Aaron成为了他们讨论这个道具创作的联络人。Randy说，当他和Phil第一次读到这个故事弧时，他们以为这个装置是编剧们在互联网上看到的某个东西，他们想知道在哪里买。结果，Ange，它根本不存在。他们编出来的？是的，他们编出来的。我甚至去看了剧本的重写版，剧本里没有对这个机器的描述。
for it for years. Lacey, I thought the same thing. I thought, can I get one of these? Well, Randy told me that this was not in the first shooting draft of the script. This whole runner was added later, and he believes that it was the master of the cold opens Aaron Scherr who wrote this story arc because Aaron became the point person that they went to to discuss the creation of this prop. Randy said when he and Phil first read this story arc, they assumed that this contraption was something the writers had seen on the internet somewhere, and they wanted to know where do they buy it. It turns out, Ange, it did not exist anywhere. They made it up? Yeah, they made it up. I even went to the rewrite of the script, and there is no scripted description of this machine.
所以Phil需要构思、设计并建造一个能工作的胡桃夹子道具，看起来像是一把枪，他只有不到一周的时间来做。Phil Shea。这就是他总是奔波的原因，伙计们。Phil去了他常去的道具制造厂，手工道具室。Randy说，那个设施的团队理所当然地被他们创造这个道具的极短时间吓坏了。他们告诉Phil去告诉Randy打开公司支票簿。他们将不得不让一整队工程师和建筑师基本上全天候工作，以便及时完成。Randy说，值得称赞的是，他们做得非常出色，这个道具总共花费了大约19,000美元。而且，它是独一无二的。他说，据他所知，NBC
So Phil needed to conceptualize design and build a working nutcracker prop that looked like it could have been a gun, and he had less than a week to do it. Phil Shea. This is why he was always running folks. Phil went to his go to props manufacturing house, the hand prop room. The team at that facility, Randy said was understandably freaked out at the very short time span that they had to create this prop. They told Phil to tell Randy to open up the company checkbook. They were going to have to put a full team of engineers and builders basically around the clock to get this done in time. Randy said to their credit, they did a masterful job all in this prop cost about $19,000. Also, it was a one-off. He said to the best of his knowledge, the NBC
环球营销人员从未为在线销售制作过这个的复制品。他们应该做的。他们仍然可以。我只是说，这将是节日里的热门商品。是的。你知道有多少人会买这个吗？我会的。我也会。但我必须把它组装起来吗？哦，不。如果你必须呢？那将是终极体验。我知道。你知道，这个故事让我想起了一位化妆师曾经告诉我的事情。她说，这个行业里有一句谚语。它叫“快、便宜或好”。你只能拥有这三件事中的两件。它可以又快又便宜，但看起来不会好。它可以又便宜又好，但不会快。如果你想让它又快又好，它就不会便宜。这就是我们的情况
Universal Marketing people never made replicas of this for online sales. They should have. They still can. I'm just saying, this would be a hot item at the holidays. Yeah. Do you know how many people would buy this? I would. I would too. But do I have to put it together? Oh no. What if you do? That would be the ultimate. I know. You know, this story reminds me of something that I had a makeup artist tell me once. She said, there is a saying in this business. It's called fast, cheap or good. And you can only have two of the three things. It can be fast and cheap, but it's not going to look good. It can be cheap and good, but it's not going to be fast. If you want it to be both fast and good, it's not going to be cheap. That was the case with
胡桃夹子。快且好。它不会便宜。不。好吧，Jenna，Mindy也在评论音轨中谈到了这个场景，她说这是一个临时的重写，它不在她最初的草稿中。她说它是Aaron Schur和Charlie Grandy写的，Mindy说Phil Shea做得非常出色，特别是因为它是一个临时的道具梗。她还评论说，这是Greg的一个建议，给这一集增加一个Dwight和Michael的故事线，它在最后得到了很好的回报。这是Michael救赎的时刻。是的。是的，他太了解Dwight了。是的，这是一个很好的建议。是的。好吧，派对要结束了。每个人都要离开过夜了。他们正走向停车场。有雪。感觉太
our Nutcracker. Fast and good. It was not going to be cheap. Nope. Well, Jenna Mindy also spoke about this scene on the commentary, and she said it was a last-minute rewrite that it was not in her original draft. She said it was written by Aaron Schur and Charlie Grandy, and Mindy said Phil Shea went above and beyond, especially because it was a last-minute prop gag. She also commented that it was a note from Greg to add a Dwight Michael storyline to this episode, and it pays off so nicely at the end. It's a moment of redemption for Michael. Yes. Yeah, he knows Dwight so well. Yeah, it's a good note. Yeah. Well, the party is wrapping up. Everyone is leaving for the night. They're walking out into the parking lot. There's snow. It feels so
我们的胡桃夹子。又快又好。这可不便宜。没错。嗯，珍娜·费舍和敏迪也在评论音轨里谈到了这一幕，她说这是最后一刻才重写的，原本的草稿里并没有。她说这是亚伦·舒尔和查理·格兰迪写的，敏迪说菲尔·谢做得非常出色，尤其是因为这是一个临时加的道具梗。她还提到这是格雷格给出的建议，要求在这一集中加入德怀特和迈克尔的故事线，最后的效果非常好。这对迈克尔来说是一个救赎的时刻。是的。没错，他太了解德怀特了。是的，这是一个很好的建议。是的。好吧，派对要结束了。大家都要回家了。他们正走向停车场。外面在下雪。感觉真
Christmassy and festive. That's right. You know, as you're walking out, Angela, I don't know if you noticed this, but we got a fan question from Kelsey D. in Orlando, Florida. I noticed when everyone is leaving the office, Angela slips, and Darryl is there to help her. Did Angela actually slip or was that planned? Because I love that moment. It's so cute and sweet between Angela and Darryl. Okay. Kelsey, I did actually trip and I grabbed Craig's arm. So that quick moment you're seeing, that's us. We're not in character. And I think Rain must have seen it and improvised the line as Dwight. Watch out. It's slippery out here because that line is not in the shooting draft. Me slipping and tripping is obviously not in the shooting draft. So yes, that's just me and Craig. And
充满圣诞气息。没错。你知道吗，安吉拉，当你走出来的时候，我不知道你有没有注意到，我们收到了佛罗里达州奥兰多市凯尔西·D的粉丝提问。我注意到当大家离开办公室时，安吉拉滑倒了，达里尔在那里扶她。安吉拉是真的滑倒了还是计划好的？因为我喜欢那一刻。安吉拉和达里尔之间太可爱、太甜蜜了。好吧。凯尔西，我确实绊倒了，我抓住了克雷格的手臂。所以你看到的那个瞬间，那是我们真实的反应。我们当时并没有在演戏。我想雷恩一定看到了，并即兴说了那句台词：小心，外面很滑。因为那句台词不在拍摄剧本里。我滑倒和绊倒显然也不在拍摄剧本里。所以是的，那只是我和克雷格的真实互动。而且
thank goodness he was there. I turned my ankle or something. Well, all of a sudden we hear something. It's drummers. It's 12 drummers drumming. This is Aaron's final Christmas present from Andy. Andy is on the symbols. He starts dancing. It's so festive. We had a fan catch from Rachel I in Phoenix, Arizona, who said, there are only 11 people in the drum line. Was Andy meant to be the 12th person? Yes. Rachel, he was the 12th percussionist in this drum line. We also got a question from Maria S. in Austin, Texas, who asked, what was the process for choosing this group that played the 12 drummers drumming? And Emily B. from Torrance, California said, I want to give a shout out to the RCC marching tigers who are the drum line featured in this episode. RCC has a fall marching
谢天谢地他在那里。我扭伤了脚踝之类的。好吧，突然我们听到了一些声音。是鼓手。是12个鼓手在击鼓。这是亚伦送给安迪的最后一份圣诞礼物。安迪在敲镲。他开始跳舞。太有节日气氛了。我们收到了亚利桑那州凤凰城瑞秋·I的粉丝反馈，她说，鼓队里只有11个人。安迪本来应该是第12个人吗？是的。瑞秋，他就是这支鼓队的第12位打击乐手。我们还收到了德克萨斯州奥斯汀市玛丽亚·S的问题，她问，选择这组演奏12个鼓手击鼓的团队的过程是什么？来自加利福尼亚州托伦斯市的艾米丽·B说，我想向RCC行进老虎队致敬，他们是本集中出现的鼓队。RCC有一个秋季行进
band program and also a winter percussion program that is one of the best independent performance groups in the country. You can see more about them at RCC Drums on IG. She said, my husband is the battery captain head and a ranger for the group, which means he writes the music and teaches the students how to play their instruments. So it is always so fun when I see RCC on a show. They've been on Parks and Rec too. Emily, thank you so much for sending that in. Randy confirmed that everything Emily said is correct. He said that he would always reach out to a woman named Christine Day. She is a music contractor and she finds musical on-screen performers. Randy said there was just no one better than her. He actually said, quote, she is well known across
乐队项目，还有一个冬季打击乐项目，是全国最好的独立表演团体之一。你可以在Instagram上通过RCC Drums了解更多关于他们的信息。她说，我丈夫是该团体的打击乐队长和编排，这意味着他负责写音乐并教学生如何演奏乐器。所以每当我在节目中看到RCC时，总是非常开心。他们也上过《公园与游憩》。艾米丽，非常感谢你发来这些信息。兰迪证实了艾米丽所说的一切都是正确的。他说他总是会联系一位名叫克里斯汀·戴的女士。她是一位音乐承包商，负责寻找屏幕上的音乐表演者。兰迪说没有人比她更好了。他甚至引用说，她在
the industry for her cheerful professionalism and ability to grasp the essence of a script and the showrunner's intent. All in, including Christine's fee, the marching band cost us $9,950. Well, I will put the RCC Drums Instagram in our story so you guys can see what they're up to. I loved learning all of that. Well, we had so much fun on this night with this marching band. I'll never forget it. I mean, we got to stay late. We always love to stay late. We did it so rarely. And then we had snow. We had snow with this like amazing drumming as a backdrop. Incredible. I asked Randy if we used snow business again. And he said, no, not this time. It was Ron Neri's group, ANA Special Effects in Van Nuys. He said, in order to get that snow in our parking
业内以其开朗的专业精神和把握剧本精髓及制片人意图的能力而闻名。包括克里斯汀的费用在内，行进乐队总共花费了9950美元。好吧，我会把RCC Drums的Instagram放到我们的故事里，这样你们就能看到他们的动态了。我很高兴了解到这一切。好吧，那天晚上我们和这支行进乐队玩得很开心。我永远不会忘记它。我的意思是，我们不得不留得很晚。我们总是喜欢留得很晚。我们很少这样做。然后我们有了雪。我们在这种令人惊叹的鼓声背景下有了雪。太不可思议了。我问兰迪我们是否再次使用了雪景特效公司。他说，不，这次不是。是罗恩·内里的团队，位于范奈斯的ANA特效公司。他说，为了让停车场有雪，
lot, they had to call this place Union Ice in North Hollywood. And they brought two semi-tractor trailer rigs full of ice. Two. Wow. And then Ron's team put the ice through an industrial chipper and it like shot it into the air. He said we shot that scene on a Friday night and it had been 78 degrees that day. He said all of the snow effects for this episode, filling the parking lot as well as that little snowfall behind our windows, that cost $36,000 for snow. For snow on a day where it was almost 80 degrees. You know, it's always fascinating to me when Randy shares with us how much something cost in an episode because it's like he had to budget all of that. Yeah. And in the budget for each episode does not change week to week, but the demands change. Yeah. So he would
他们不得不打电话给北好莱坞的Union Ice公司。他们带来了两辆装满冰块的半挂卡车。两辆。哇。然后罗恩的团队把冰块放进工业碎冰机里，它就像把它射向空中一样。他说我们在周五晚上拍摄了那场戏，那天有78华氏度。他说这一集所有的雪景特效，填满停车场以及窗外那点小雪，雪的成本是36000美元。在气温接近80华氏度的一天里下雪。你知道，每当兰迪和我们分享一集花了多少钱时，我总是觉得很着迷，因为他必须为所有这些做预算。是的，每一集的预算每周都不会变，但需求会变。是的。所以他会
have this elaborate spreadsheet and he would have to figure out how to make all these little details happen. He needed to get the geese and the spawns and the special prop and the snow and the drumline and make it all cost the same as an episode that didn't even have all those things. Right. It's really fascinating to me. But you know, I love a spreadsheet. I know you do. Well, you know, Mindy was talking in the commentary about the scene about how hard Ed had to work as Andy doing the running man dancing with the symbols. And we did a lot of takes and she was like, do you guys remember? He was like sweating. He did such a good job. I know. Well, that is how the episode ends. However, we got a fan question from Katie G in Greenville, South Carolina.
有一个复杂的电子表格，他必须想出如何实现所有这些小细节。他需要弄到鹅、产卵、特殊的道具、雪和鼓队，并使它们的总成本与没有所有这些东西的一集相同。对。这对我来说真的很迷人。但你知道，我喜欢电子表格。我知道你喜欢。好吧，你知道，明迪在评论中谈到这一幕时，说埃德作为安迪敲着镲跳“奔跑人”舞有多辛苦。我们拍了很多次，她说，你们记得吗？他当时汗流浃背。他做得太棒了。我知道。好吧，这就是这一集的结尾。然而，我们收到了南卡罗来纳州格林维尔市凯蒂·G的粉丝提问。
In the DVD commentary, Mindy teases that Greg had an alternate ending for this episode, but she was not going to tell us what it was. She kind of just says, you'll have to ask Greg. Yeah. What was the ending Katie wants to know? Well, Katie, I heard this conversation too. It happens as the credits, you know, are going at the end. And our editor Claire Scanlon jumps in and says she actually cut out the scene. Well, listen, we wanted to get to the bottom of this. We wanted to mom detectives this and actually solve this one. Will we do it? I started by reaching out to Greg Daniels, and he did not remember. I reached out to Claire Scanlon, who enlisted the help of Rob Burnett, the office writer's assistant. Rob went through his digital clutter
在DVD评论中，明迪调侃说格雷格为这一集准备了一个替代结局，但她不会告诉我们那是什么。她只是说，你得去问格雷格。是的。凯蒂想知道结局是什么？好吧，凯蒂，我也听到了这段对话。它发生在片尾字幕滚动的时候。我们的剪辑师克莱尔·斯坎伦插话说她实际上剪掉了那一幕。好吧，听着，我们想查个水落石出。我们想像妈妈侦探一样解决这个问题。我们会成功吗？我首先联系了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，他不记得了。我联系了克莱尔·斯坎伦，她寻求了《办公室》编剧助理罗伯·伯内特的帮助。罗伯翻阅了他的数字杂物
and found a tag in a late rewrite of the script. And then Claire found the footage. That's right. It is a scene where Pam sees Oscar and Matt walking away from the drumline group. They're going to go back inside. Pam follows them in, but then quickly comes back out of the building and it is clear that she has seen them making out. So that was the surprise ending that Matt and Oscar hook up at work. Now, this is very funny to me, Angela, because Pam has now caught Phyllis and Bob in a bathroom at lunch. And now she has caught Matt and Oscar in the hall closet. I mean, how many people are getting it on at work or during work hours? Well, we haven't even brought up Kelly and Ryan. And then, of course, Dwight and Angela don't get me started,
并在剧本的后期修改中找到了一个标签。然后克莱尔找到了这段录像。没错。这是一个场景，帕姆看到奥斯卡和马特从鼓队那边走开。他们要回到里面去。帕姆跟着他们进去，但很快又从大楼里出来，很明显她看到他们正在亲热。所以这就是那个惊喜结局，马特和奥斯卡在工作中勾搭上了。现在，这对我来说非常有趣，安吉拉，因为帕姆已经在午餐时的浴室里抓到过菲利斯和鲍勃了。现在她又在走廊的壁橱里抓到了马特和奥斯卡。我的意思是，有多少人在工作或工作时间内搞在一起？好吧，我们甚至还没提到凯利和瑞恩。当然，还有德怀特和安吉拉，别让我开始说，
but Pam and Jim had a pretty steamy kiss one time after hours. Well, that's true. Well, you know, later, it's sort of speculated that Jim and Pam make their second baby at work. It's on Valentine's Day. Right. And then Michael and Holly are in the stairwell. Yeah, they forgot to lock the door. That leads to the entire robbery of crime aid. I mean, this place is a hot bed of hookups. A hot bed of hookups. Wait a second. Did mom detectives just solve one? We solved one and I feel very good about solving one. I am so excited that we got to the bottom of that. Claire and Rob, thank you so much. Yes. They sent us this footage, you guys. It's pretty special. The cast ends up in a snowball
但帕姆和吉姆有一次下班后有一个相当热烈的吻。好吧，那是真的。好吧，你知道，后来有人推测吉姆和帕姆在工作中怀上了他们的第二个孩子。那是在情人节。对。然后迈克尔和霍莉在楼梯间。是的，他们忘了锁门。这导致了整个犯罪援助的抢劫。我的意思是，这个地方是勾搭的温床。勾搭的温床。等一下。妈妈侦探刚刚解决了一个案子吗？我们解决了一个，我感觉解决了一个案子非常好。我很高兴我们查清了真相。克莱尔和罗伯，非常感谢。是的。他们把这段录像发给了我们，伙计们。它非常特别。演员们最终打了一场雪仗
fight once again. Yeah. It really brought me back. What an amazing time in our lives, Jenna. And how lucky we get to rewatch this together. I know. It's bringing back all of these warm memories for me. I just love it. I love doing this podcast every week. And we love it when you guys reach out to us and tell us different things that mean something to you. It brightens our whole day. Well, thank you for all of your fan questions. Just a reminder, you submit fan questions by going to OfficeLadies.com. We have a little folder you can click on and you can submit for any episode by folder. Jenna's very excited about the folders, guys. I am. Very excited. Thanks once again to Randy Cordray, Claire Scanlon, Rob Burnett, Greg Daniels,
又一次。是的。它真的把我带回去了。我们生命中多么美妙的时光啊，珍娜。我们能一起重温这一集是多么幸运。我知道。它勾起了我所有温暖的回忆。我只是喜欢它。我喜欢每周做这个播客。我们喜欢你们联系我们并告诉我们对你们有意义的不同事情。这照亮了我们的一整天。好吧，感谢你们所有的粉丝提问。提醒一下，你们可以通过访问OfficeLadies.com提交粉丝提问。我们有一个小文件夹，你可以点击它，按文件夹为任何一集提交问题。珍娜对文件夹非常兴奋，伙计们。我是。非常兴奋。再次感谢兰迪·科德雷、克莱尔·斯坎伦、罗伯·伯内特、格雷格·丹尼尔斯，
Joya Balfour, and my friend, my personal friend who I can text anytime I want. Lead singer of Green Day, Billy Jones. You guys have a great week. Thank you for listening to OfficeLadies. OfficeLadies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of OfficeLadies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
乔亚·巴尔福，还有我的朋友，我可以随时发短信给我的私人朋友。绿日乐队的主唱，比利·琼斯。祝你们度过愉快的一周。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。